اتذكر كنت في اسبانيا ذاك الوقت كان كان
في صديق هناك وقال لي ترى هذا الرجال اللي
بيشوفك وبيجي مخصوص يعني عشان يقابلك
يوم جاني قال لي هذا العمل لازم يوقف
كيف قال لي ابدا هذا العمل مرفوض تماما من
المؤسسه الدينيه قاطبه وراح يجتمع مجلس
او هيئه الكبار العلم هيئه كبار العلماء
وراح يستلم بيان والعمل بيوقفها احسن لك
وقفه من عندك قلت له طيب على فكره ترى قطر
مشاركينا بالعمل ترى اذا وقفتهم بيعرضونه
يعني قال ما يع
رضون
المنحطه ام
بي سي
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي ضيف حلقه اليوم هو الاستاذ
وليد ال ابراهيم مؤسس ورئيس مجلس اداره
قناه ام بي سي او مجموعه ام بي سي تكلمنا
في الحلقه عن توثيق تاريخي لهذه المجموعه
الاعلاميه الرائده في العالم العربي من
التسعينات مرحله لندن تحدياتها والدعم
الحكومي
والانتشار العربي الى مرحله دبي والتوسع
في القنوات من قناه واحده الى اكثر من
عشرين قناه
والدخول لعالم
المنصات على الانترنت ودخول القنوات
الرياضيه ثم التعثر والخروج من هذا القطاع
الى تاسيس قناه اخباريه بكل ما في ذلك من
كواليس واجتماعات مع الزعماء العرب
واحداث مثيره جدا في هذه المرحله ثم
انتهينا بمرحله رؤيه السعوديه عشان
المرحله القادمه في مجموعه ام بي سي
شراكات مع نيو مع الجديه مع هيئه الترفيه
التحول اللي تعيش السعوديه كيف يخدم ام بي
سي وكيف ام بي سي تخدمه وهذا اللقاء صور
اليوم في مقر ام بي سي في الرياض بعد 30
سنه من وجود هذه القناه خارج السعوديه
اترككم مع الحوار حياك الله ابو خالد شرفت
ونورتنا هلا والله اخيرا قناه السعوديه
رجعت السعوديه
فمنزل مباركة ومكتب مبارك نقول الله يبارك
فيك حلم
الحمد لله
موجودين في الحي الدبل في الرياض بعد 30
سنه نعم وهذه يمكن اهم جزء من حلقه اليوم
ابو خالد اننا نعرف قصه 30 سنه هذه الرحله
اللي ادت الى خلق امبراطوريه اعلاميه
كبيره او رائده وفيها كثير من محطات
الجوهريه
فخلينا ابدا واقول وش يخلي رجل مثلك من
اسره قد لا تحتاج تدخل الاعلام يدخل
هالعالم مش القصه صدفه بحته والله شلون
يعني انا تخرجت من امريكا
وفتحت مكتب
في الرياض
ما ادري ايش بسوي ما كان في عندي اي تصور
كانت شاركت انا واخواني كان سعود وماجد
ومحمد احنا الاربعه
قررنا انه نعمل شركه
ونشوف يعني ذاك الوقت طبعا كان فيه
طفره
الثمانينات بدايه الثمانينات وكان نسمع
دائما ما شاء الله الناس يعني تشتغل
الدوله كانت
فاتحه المجال للشباب السعودي
كان عندك خيارين اما تروح تشتغل في احدى
القطاعات الحكوميه او الشركات تتابع
الحكومه
او انك تروح
تحاول انك تعمل شيء يعني فاحنا قررنا انه
انا
بتولى هذه الجزئيه اللي هي محاوله
نعمل بزنس
كانت المرحله الاولى مرحله فقط يعني دراسه
استكشاف ايه هو مكان الاعلام جزء من الخطه
اصلا ابدا ابدا بس ما كان في شيء يعني
واضح او محدد اساسا يعني بالصدفه كان
في صديق قال لي على مخرج
سعودي
قال في عنده فكره
مسلسل يسوونه مع ممثل
لبناني قديم اسمه رشيد اعلام
وهذا انا كنت احبه يعني من ايام التلفزيون
الابيض واسود وهو يعمل اعمال بالعربيه
الفصحى
اعمال تاريخيه الاصمعي ويعمل كمان كانوا
يعملون حتى مسلسلات مودرن بس بالفصحى برضو
يعني
اعتقد كان الهدف من التوزيع لان اللهجه
اللبنانيه يمكن يخافون من بعض القنوات
وبعض الدول ما تاخذها
فيحطونها بالفصحى يضمنون انه تتوزع على
اكبر عدد من
الدول ذاك الوقت ما في قنوات في كلها دول
يعني
تلفزيونات تابع لوزارات الاعلام الحكوميه
فجاني انا طبعا يعني ما اخذت الموضوع
بجديه ابدا بس كنت ابي اشوف رصيد علامه
يعني هذا كان الهدف
فالجون المكتب وجلسنا
بعد ما خلصنا
وطلع
الممثل رشيد علامه
المخرج اللي جاب قال لها وش رايك بموضوع
قلت والله بدرسه يعني بس انا اشك هذا
المجال يعني بدخل فيه يعني
ميزانيه محدوده فانت شوي
تعمل حساباتك قبل ما تاخذ
سوري كمان
قلت له قلت له
ارجع لي وبشوف بدرس الموضوع وكان عندي
واحد
جبت كان مساعد ذاك الوقت معاي
فراح عمل دراسه سريعه كذا خلال يومين او
ثلاثه ورجع وقال لي شوف الارقام اللي
جايبينها من الناحيه النظريه صحيحه يعني
اعتقد تكلفه 500 الف ريال
والدخل من بيطلع له حوالي 800 و900 الف لو
كل الدول شرتها قال اول شيء عندك
عامل انه حل الدول كلها تشتريها ولا لا
هذا غير معروف ثاني شيء
حتى لو اشتروها من يدفع
ومتى يدفع فيعني انت داخل في سكه ما نعرف
لها اول من اخر ولا يعني ما اعتقد انها
مجديه
فاخذت صراحه نصيحته وقلت للرجال قلت والله
بس ترى موضوع غير مجدي بالنسبه لنا وكذا
فقال لي طيب عندي لك فكره ثانيه ليش ما
نعمل يعني انا عندي
وعجبتني
واشتغلنا عليها وقلت لهم اوكي اذا بنسويها
ما حروح اقدم يعني عرض
مكتوب على ورق افضل انه اعمل على الاقل
فيلم واحد
يبين احد المشاريع يعني اللي موجوده واحد
القطاعات
واعرض على
الوزاره يعني
معرض على باقي المشروع اخترنا اعتقد عشرين
موضوع وعشرين فيلم وقتها
وسويت موعد مع مدير مكتب وزير الاعلام كان
على الشاعر ذاك الوقت
ويوم جاء اليوم اللي المفروض اقابل على
الشعر فيه رحت دخلت على مكتب
مدير مكتبه
وقال لي
تفضل بس ترى الشاعر مو في في مهمه رسميه
او شيء
والوزير اللي بالنيابه موجود ابراهيم
العنقلي الشيخ ابراهيم العنقري الله يرحمه
فانا شوي شوي انصدمت من الموضوع لان انا
كان ودي تعرف احد اتابع معاه وبيحد يعني
الشيخ ابراهيم كان جاي مؤقت
وعاده الوزير اذا اذا
جاء مكان الوزير الاخر او كذا كنا نسمع
انه ما ياخذ قرارات يعني ما يشربك نفسه
خلفيات كافيه
مع انه الشيخ ابراهيم العنقلي ترى كان
وزير السابق فيعني الموضوع الاعلام مو
غريب عليه اعتقد يمكن عشان كذا هو ناب عن
اهل الشاعر
فالمهم دخلت عليه واعرفه طبعا بس
سلمت وكذا وايش عندك يقول لي اعطيت الخطاب
الظرف وانا احط فيها الشريط اللي فيه
الفيلم اللي احنا صورناه والفيلم الظاهر
على كلامك انك كنت تعبتوا عليها
حطيت عليه
حق الشركه من راس المال هذا ما يعني
بالنسبه لي كان هو اهم عندي اهم نقطه
الاقناعين ويشوف الفيلم طبعا هذا الافكار
كله نقدم افكار بس تقدر تسوي
الله يرحمها اخذ الخطاب طلعوا الفيلم
موجود داخل الظرف ما طلعه طلع الخطاب قرعه
اخذت قلم كتب
الحين
ما جاز للموضوع يعني لانه يعني مش كتابه
نبي نشوف الفيلم يعني يناقشني
اعطاه الطرف بالشريط
انا الصراحه جدا
التفت عليه
قالوا غيره كيف غير
قال لي اسمع انت انا قريت كتابك
في الخطاب شرح للمشروع المشروع فيه عشرين
اعتقد والله عشرين ماده ما احنا من الرقم
مواضيع افلام مثلا
كل قطاعات يعني طبعا
ومغري لاني احنا مخرج اجنبي بعد يعني ابغى
شيء يفهم عليه اكثر يعني
فكم سهل بالنسبه له انه يفهم الموضوع
وبعدين يعني كل القطاعات يعني حلو
اخذ
قال لي
انا قريت الخطاب وشفت المواضيع اللي انت
حاطها هذا كافي بالنسبه لي اني ارفع فيه
هذه القرار مو عندي بس انا برفع ورفعت
بالتاييد
ليه تكشفت
الشريط قال لا اللي بيقرر هو اللي يشوفه
بس انا رفعت على المواضيع اللي موجوده
وخلي اللي يقرر هو اللي
ذاك الوقت ما وضح لي انها الملك فهد قال
برفع فيها ايه
اتوقع يعني
هي واضحه ان الملك فهد بس يعني الاقرب
انها تكون راحت للملك او رئيس مجلس
الوزراء ويعني مكان وانا ما كنت افهم لا
في الدوله ولا انظمه الدوله ولا وطلعت
وانا مرتبك اتذكر حتى بشتي
[ضحك]
نصدمت من الموقف واول تجربه لي يعني مع
الحكومه بشكل عام اول تجربه فطلعت
وانا قلت يعني اكيد بيوصل اذا الملك مو هو
اللي شايف الفيلم اكيد بيوصل لمنحه خبر او
فنروح الله يرحم الملك فهد دائما يعني اما
اكون عندهم على الغداء ولا العشاء ولا كذا
اكون موجود
وانتظر اسمع شيء يسمع شيء ما في مر شهر
تقريبا وزياده
وبديت بيني وبينك
يعني لا يعني يعني كذا تعرف اللي
اليوم كنا نتغدى في جده مع الملك فهد الله
يرحمه
عقب الغدر راح قاعد في المجلس
ونداني قال لي حط هذا الشريط في الفيديو
حطه
ابدا ما جاء على بالي انه هذا هو
يعني بيفتح موضوع ولا بيقول لي شيء ابدا
حطيتك
يوم
تشوفني كيف
قعدنا نتفرج كلنا
معلق ما قال ولا كلمه
يطالع طالع طالع لين خلص من اول الفيلم
لين اخر
الوثائق اللي انا عارفه
يوم خلص
التفت علي قال اخذ طلع الخطاب مكتوب عليه
من ابراهيم
وقال لي وش انت مسوي مع ابراهيم العنقر
اللي قاعد يمدح مشروعكم هذا يقول
وكتب عليه بعدين حط ذي الورقه والقلم
والتفت علي
قال لي هذا مشروع ممتاز وحنا في حاجه لا
وهذا بيعرض في خارج المملكه في سفارات وفي
اماكن
محافل وغيرها كان ذاك الوقت الملك سلمان
الله يحفظك كان
عندهم
ياخذون شو اسمه كان للرياض شيء عن عن
الرياض معرض الرياض بين الامس واليوم كان
يروح يدور في دول مختلفه وكذا
فقال هذا احنا محتاجين هالنوع من ده لكن
ابي الافلام الباقيه او انها ما تقل عن
اللي شفت لان اللي شفت جازلي فهو على اللي
شافه
لا يقل الثاني لا يقولون
كنت محبيت يدو الله يطول عمرك اكيد يعني
طبعا هذه خلاص يعني بالنسبه لي انه
عجبه حتى لو لو عجبه حتى لو ما اعطاني
المشروع هذا كافي بالنسبه لي خصوصا الله
يرحمك كان ما هو راضي عن
التفاعل الاعلام مع انجازات وحراك
ابراهيم العنقري قال لي السبب اني وافقت
عليه لانه حنا كلنا عندنا
مشكله في
انه
الانجازات اللي قاعده تصير قاعده تظهر
الناس ما ما وصلتهم بالشكل الصحيح
وبدانا مشروع برنامج سعودي
المخرج اللي
صاحب الفكره اللي جاني بالبدايه وقال لي
عليها انا دخلت معنا شريك 20% وقتها كنا
انا واخواني الاربعه فهو الخامس انه يكون
معنا شريك
وفي شركه الانتاج هذا شركه الانتاج
واخذنا لهم نذكر بالله في السليمانيه
وجاب مخرجين وكروز وما اعرف ايش وبداوا
يشتغلون والله
انقطعت عنهم فتره يمكن شهرين ثلاثه
الفلانيه تكلمنا مسؤول الفلاني ما اعرف
ايش
هذا بالتليفون بس يوم جديد ابغى اشوف
وروني
ففي شيء اسمه
يعني
الصوره النهائيه
بدها جاء اول واحد مخرجين مخرجين كانوا من
احد البلدان العربيه
فعرض الفيلم ما جاهز لي ابدا طبعا قلت له
شكرا
يعني من نص الفيلم وانا متضايق
ابدا بعيد جدا الجهه الثاني ولا العام جاء
الثالث الرابع ما صبرت يعني من اول خمس
دقايق قلت له وقف وقف وانتم جايكم تعميد
على اربعه افلام لا لا
اول اربعه
مع بعض
والملك كان حاس قال لك لا ينزل الجوده عن
اهل شفناه
هذه بضاعتك لا يجيني شيء بكره مختلف وهذا
طبعا كلام
منطقي وصحيح يعني المهم
هذا ما كان موجود الشخص المخرج ده
الشريك اللي معنا ما كان موجود وقت ما شفت
الافلام
فرحت المكتب انا في
عماره الملك فيصل الخيريه
وناديته
قلت له فلان
اريك تعطيني من وجهه نظرك
كيف لانه هو اللي يدير المشروع يعني انت
كيف عامل
التقديراتك على الربح من المشروع هذا يعني
بعد في نهايه المشروع وش تتوقع انه احنا
حنعمل من المبلغ اللي احنا اتفقنا مع
الحكومه عليه
قال اعطاني الرقم
وقتها اعتقد
عشره مليون ريال قال لي
انه بنربح عشره مليون ريال اعتقد رقم
الكلي كان 27 مليون
ناديت المحاسب بتعطني شيك كتبت شيك
بمليونين تحصتك من العشره مليون مليونين
ريال هذا ربحك وابغى بنفس الوقت توقع
ورقتها تنازل عن حصتك لاني انا ما هستمر
بالمشروع واذا انا سويت المشروع بطريقتي
يمكن ما تربح للمليونين يعني
انا مو بهدفي الربح هذا الان انا عندي
الموضوع صار بالنسبه لي موضوع
ببني عليه
ثقه مسؤولين كثير يعني
وهذا حيقرر كيف حاشتغل في المستقبل
موضوع
بالنسبه لي وهو كان واضح انه يبغى يستغل
الفرصه بانه يخفض الكوست او يخفض التكلفه
مبلغ كبير في فرصتك في الوقت يعني كم مبلغ
كبير يعني
اتفقنا وطلع الرجال
احلى ربح باقل مجهول
فجبت
علي الحديثي ابو فيصل كان انا وعلي زميل
الدراسه معي في امريكا
وفي ذيك اللحظه صراحه ما كنت يعني خلص ما
عاد الموضوع بالنسبه لي موضوع تخصص في
اختيار الشخص الحين صار موضوع ثقه لان ابي
شخص يفهم انا وين بروح ويفهم هذا المشروع
وشيء بالنسبه لي
وينفذ اللي انا ابيه ما عاد يعني ما عاد
ابي منه يعني
اضافه بس بنفس الوقت بنجيب يعني الناس
اللي هم
متخصصين في هذه النوعيه من الاعمال
ويعطيهم
المجال انهم هم يبدعون بطريقتهم فيها يعني
مع اخوه عبد الله الله يعطيه العافيه
وبدانا المسيره سوا من ذاك الوقت يعني ما
شاء الله
والحمد لله
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
وش صار على العشرين فيلم
تنفذت على رقم ما يمكن جبنا مخرجين من
من كندا من بريطانيا من استراليا وعرب
اسمه مبدعين يعني عرب من
اتذكر مخرج عدنان ابراهيم الله يرحمه كان
عمل معنا عده افلام طبعا في بعض الاماكن
زي مكه والمدينه هذا لازم يكونوا مسلمين
يدخلون يصورون وربحتوا لا في هذاك المشروع
صراحه ما ربحنا بس انا يعني ما ما كان
يعنيني الموضوع هذا كثير صراحه
ديك في وقتها يعني لكن بعدين نتواصل معاي
على الشاعر الله يرحمه وقال لي
عندنا رغبه ان نعطيكم نكلفكم بعمل افلام
اضافيه انبسطوا من المجموعه الاولى
يعني وطلبوا انه نعمل اعمال
المكتب وابد اللي تامر فرحت لو اخذت معاي
كل من المحاسب تكاليف كلها
انا بوريك قدامك الحين
بشفافيه كم صرفنا كم
كلفنا الموضوع وانت احكم يعني على كيف
الافلام القادمه هذي كيف نتعامل معها
فطلع الارقام كلها
وجاب اللي عندهم في الوزاره حق الشؤون
الماليه
وقال لهم ادرسوها كمان من عندكم ودرسوها
فعلا
وتوصلنا احنا وياهم الى رقم فير يعني لنا
ولهم يعني
للعرض الجديد
ابدا وجددنا العرض معهم الثلاثين فيلم
هذيك وبعدين طلبونا مره ثانيه
كان سبعين فيلم اللي انعملت يعني على يوم
خلصت اطلب
اعمال اضافيه
المرحله انا ما كنت بوقف على اعمال
وثائقيه يعني انا خلاص دخلت المجال
فبدايات اقول طيب اوكي غير الاعمال وذلك
ايش بنسوي يعني فرحنا نبي نسوي دراما
انصدمنا او يعني
صدمنا مع الاجهزه
الاجهزه الاعلام الحكوميه في العالم
العربي يعني وين ما نروح
هذول قوانينهم تختلف عن هذولا وهذولا
عندهم
رقابه
تختلف عن الرقابه اللي هنا
وفساد في بعض المحطات التلفزيون اللي ما
يدخلون اعمال
يكونون لهم مصلحه فيها
فموضوع شائك جدا يعني
احنا بنوقف بس نعمل افلام مثلكيه يعني من
هنا بدات فكره ام بي سي او يعني قناه انه
طيب ليش حنا ما نعمل قناه ليش نروح
يعني تحت رحمه الاجهزه الحكوميه هذي في 22
دوله عربيه
وبدات فكره ام بي سي
قدمت
لمحمد النويصر الله يرحمه
خطاب كان وقتها
الملكي
وقدمت الخطاب للملكه الرئيس مجلس الوزراء
انه احنا نرغب كذا كذا
بعد فتره كلمني محمد النسر وقال لي ترى
انا عرضت الموضوع على
مولاي وانه يقول
في صالح كامل مقدم بعد انهم يعملون قناه
فليش ما تجتمعون انتم واياهم
وتتفقون مع بعض ما يكون فيه مشروعين
مختلفه
قال لي اجل انا برتب الموعد واعلمك فعلا
كلمني احد من مكتبه بعدها يمكن ايام
وقالوا لي الموعد اليوم الفلاني تجون
رحت وكان صالح كامل هناك ما كنت تعرف صالح
كامل اول مره اول مره قابليه اسمع فيه
طبعا رجل اعمال كبير ومعروف لكن ما ما
يعني
فرق السن بيني وبينه
من امريكا ذاك الوقت
صالح كامل هم طبعا فكره القناه عندها
تختلف شوي عننا حنا نتصالح كامل كان
هو ينتج عندهم شركه اسمها الشركه العربيه
في مصر ينتجون مسلسلات
واعتقد افلام بس يعني اكثر مسلسلات كانت
للمحطات التلفزيون العربيه كلها
في الاردن كان عندهم استوديوهات في الاردن
بعد بس بس مختصين يعني متوجهين
للتلفزيونات الحكوميه فصار عنده
مكتبه
باعمال
كثيره
فيبون هذه الاعمال انهم
يستفيدون منها بعد ما تنتهي
اللايسنس او
الرخصه الجهه الحكوميه اللي تاخذها ترجع
لهم الاعمال
يبيع القناه السعوديه مده حقوق سنتين
انتهت سنتين ترجع فعنده هو مسلسل غير
مستغرب ويعيد استغلاله وتدويره تدوير حلو
بس حنا لا احنا انا فكرتي لا انه فكرتي
ابغى انطلق بشيء فوق
اعلى من اللي يقدمون القنوات الحكوميه
يعني انه على مستوى اللي قدم في اوروبا في
امريكا
ونرتقي بالصناعه وبنفس الوقت يعني
الانتشار طبعا
فشوي هذه الرؤيه صارت شوي مختلفه بيننا
لكن لكن اتفقنا عليها بالاخير
يمكن شيء
يعني بينه وبينهم
وبدانا العمل تاسست
انا
كان المفروض تمتلك عام 90
صارت حرب الكويت
فطبعا اثناء حرب الكويت ما صعب انك تترك
قناه
وبنفس الوقت
مساله كيف
القناه يعني انا كنت مامن طبعا انه الملك
فهد
بيعطينا بث ارضي في السعوديه يعني كان على
اساس انه قال اجتمعوا مع بعض وكذا فتوقعت
انه اذا طلعت وشافها ويعني
انه ما في محاذير او شيء عليها انه
بيعطينا بث ارضي
كان هذا العمل يعني انا انا وصالح كامل
كلنا وين مقركم وين موقعكم ولا لسه
اتجاه اكثر على لندن يعني بعد يعني ما
درست عده اماكن لا كانت اتجاه اكثر على
لانه فيها المساحه اللي انتم محتاجينها
عشان تقدرون تسوون رؤيه اللي في بالكم
كانت الصحافه العربيه بلندن
موجوده ومتقدمه هناك وكان في الابحاث
التسويق الشرق الاوسط الجديده كانت في
لندن ذاك الوقت فيعني
حريه الصحافه ويعني والاعلام وذا كانت
بلندن اكثر من البلدان العربيه ذاك الوقت
فقررت انها لندن لكن قلت ممكن لبث ارضي في
السعوديه انه لا انا قلت الحين ما ابغى
افتح هذا الموضوع الحين بس تطلع اذا اثبتت
نفسها شاف انه ما فيها محاذير يعني عائله
واحنا حديثين يعني من هالناحيه كنا في
البدايات
اتذكر الله يرحمه اول يوم طلعت فيها كانت
18 سبتمبر عام 1991
اول بث كان نشره اخبار
وانا في الكنترول روم
الجاليري اللي بيطلع على المذيعين اللي
يقرون نشره في لندن ولا جاني واحد قال لي
سنترال الملك فهد الملك بيك
في تلفون في خط
كلمني كان مره مو الصوت الله يرحمه
ويعني قال كلام جدا يعني فرحني صراحه هذيك
كانت تقنيه سابقه او تقنيه تعتبر جديده
موضوع البث
ذاك الوقت
واعتقد كان في بعض القنوات الامريكيه تجي
من القاعده الامريكيه اللي في السعوديه
وقتها كان كان لهم بث بعد فنشوف بعض
القنوات الامريكيه فيعني مساله انك تشوف
بالستالايت ايه بس طبعا انك انه قناه
مستمره وتشوفها بهالطريقه لا غير يعني
وبعدين اصلا مستوى
الناس
نوعيه البرامج غير يعني كانت مختلفه كثير
وهي ابتدت كلام منوع في مسلسلات في برامج
عائليه
في المكالمه هذه
رميت عليه كلمه انه
الله يطول عمرك ترد احنا الحين بنشوف كيف
نوصل للناس يعني بدون ما اطلب يعني طلب
مباشر
قال لنا الناس هم هم بيلقونها لا تخاف
يعني
وراح الموضوع
بعد ما رجعت للمملكه
قلت له يعني شو رايك بموضوع البث يعني
يكون في
قال لي صعبه في السعوديه الان انا
ما اعتقد انه الوقت الان مناسب لهذا
الموضوع بعد حرب الكويت وبعد يعني الاوضاع
شويه
فقال لي بس وقلت له انا بنفس الوقت طيب
دول ثانيه طيب في دول يمكن ما عندهم نفس
الحساسيه يعني قال مثل مين بالكويت بعد
التحرير يعني البحرين المغرب اعطيته
كامثله يعني قال لي ابدا انا مستعد اعطيك
خطاب وتروح
ملك البحرين او ذاك الوقت كان امير
البحرين الشيخ عيسى
والامير الكويت ولا الملك الحسن
فعلا والثلاثه كلهم موافقوا وصار في بث
ارضي الام بي سي في اول سنه في البحرين
وفي الكويت وفي المغرب ذاك الوقت
حتى البحرين فيها ميزه لانها توصل المنطقه
الشرقيه في السعوديه ففي جزء من السعوديه
كان يشوف
الام بي سي ذاك الوقت
طبعا لاحقا اظن بعدين يمكن سنه وسنتين
وافق الملك انه ياخذون بس نشره اخبار ام
بي سي ويحطونا على القناه الثانيه
السعوديه
بتذكر الله شرط عليه لانه
اظن كان التلفزيون السعودي نشرتهم الساعه
تسعه ونفس الوقت او شيء قال لازم تفصلون
بنص ساعه عشان اللي بيشوف ذي وذي يقدر
يشوف الثنتين زي كذا بس حطوها على القناه
الثانيه السعوديه
والى هالوقت هذا وايش كان نوع الدعم اللي
فيه قصه طرد علي على قصه القناه الثانيه
السعوديه نشرت الاخبار
كان رئيس الحرس الملكي الله يرحمه النمله
كان
مره احنا في التنهات في البر مع الملك فهد
الله يرحمه
قاعدين على السفره وجاء الفريق النمله قال
الملك طال عمرك انا بشتكي عليك وليد
قال الملك افا وش سوى قال انا عندي اسوي
دوريه على الحرس اللي حول المخيم يعني
واذا طلعت نيكولت النوري ما لقيته راحوا
كلهم قدام بالشاشه ههه
[ضحك]
احنا في البدايه قلت لك لو اعطونا البث
الارضي كان استمرينا
كمشروع تجاري
والدراسات كلها كانت
مجديه جدا معنا طبعا لانه تاخر موضوع او
متاخر انه يعني اصبح شبه مشكوك في امره
فبدانا هنا
يعني نشوف وش الحلول الثانيه يعني وخاصه
انه صالح كامل الله يرحمه يعني بدا يتململ
شوي من الموضوع وبدا يفكر في قصه
التلفزيون المدفوع يعني المشفر
شوي انا ما اتفقت معاه بهذه النقطه من عده
نواحي يعني من ناحيه انه الناس ما تعودوا
يدفعون على على التلفزيون ذاك الوقت
ومن ناحيه ثانيه انه هذا استثمار طويل
الاجل يعني عشان يجيك مردود لازم يستنزف
عده سنوات ولا كان عندي القدره اني اجاريه
يعني
في الاستثمار
عندك منتج عالي الجوده وما في اشتراكات
وشريكك طلع ففي عندك مصاريف سنويه في دخل
احنا احنا الاعلانات ترى من ثالث سنه بدات
اول شيء وقعنا مع شركه تهامه
وبعدين عملنا شركتنا احنا ايه بس في جده
في السعوديه كان في شوي دخل يجي من
البحرين شوي من الكويت بعدين الكويت
ثالث سنه وقفوا
البث الارضي ليش والمغرب نفس الشيء المغرب
كمان يمكن ثالث او ربع سنه وقفوا بعد يعني
يمكن شافوا فيها
انها قاعده اخذ اكله الجو على القنوات
المحليه حقتهم
فشوي تعرف
عاد من وزر الاعلام وكذا انهم يعني يشوفون
فيها شوي تحدي لهم
لانهم
داخليه ما يقدرون يعني وفي هذيك المرحله
ابو خالد اللي هي مرحله صعبه ما بين
المحاوله تغطيه المصروفات ومحاوله صنع
منتج ممتاز كان صارت لك مواقف مع سفير
السعوديه في لندن ذلك الوقت
الدكتور غازي الله يرحمها
اصلا
الام بي سي بدات في 91 وظن الدكتور غازي
الله يرحمها تعين سفير 92 يعني في نفس
الفتره بس اذكر مثلا على موضوع الدعم انا
اتذكر ذاك الوقت يعني كنت اشتكي على
الدكتور غازي انا وصالح كامل كلنا نجتمع
معاه دائما في
في لندن كنا نشتكي على موضوع الدعم فهو
كان يقول يعني غريبه ليش
هو ما يحكي فقط عن المملكه يقول المملكه
ودول الدكتور غازي كان يشوف انه المملكه
ودول الخليج كتله واحده ويقول انه المملكه
ودول الخليج هذول
كانوا يعني ضحيه
لابتزاز من من الصحفيين عرب سواء اللي
كانوا في لبنان او في دول اخرى وكانوا
يجيهم معاونات كبيره جدا من دول الخليج
يعني
فتذكر كانت الدكتور غازي يقول اللي اللي
على ايدينه احنا
في السفاره نعطيهم
اكيد تقوم قناه اكبر من ام بي سي واكبر من
الشرق الاوسط الجريده يعني ذاك الوقت
وحق دول الخليج كانوا السفره يقولون نفس
الكلام يعني كلهم متفقين على هذه الجزئيه
اذكره واحد من
سفر
دوله شقيقه من دول الخليج يقول انه في
احد الصحفيين
العرب
كان يهاجم رئيس دوله
في في ضمن جريده ومجله وقتها
كلفوا السفير انه
يتفاهم معاه وكذا فظن واعطاه شيء يعني
وقتها
فيقول بعدها بفتره قابلته مره ثانيه نفس
هذا الصحفي
فقلت له طيب الحين عطينا ما عمري شفت كلمه
زينه قلتها ولا طريت البلد بشيء ولا قال
لا هذا انت معطيتوني عشان اسكت الحين
ادفعوا لي عشان امدحكم
في عنده منيو الاسعار بالضبط
ترى بدا هذا الكلام من الخمسينات
في لبنان
وقت اعتقد مصر وبعدين
استمر الين الحرب الاهليه اللبنانيه عام
معظم هذول هاجروا الى لندن وباريس يعني
وكان في عدد كبير منهم طبعا من دول عربيه
مختلفه ترى مو بس من لبنان بس كانوا
موجودين وكنا نشوفهم في
لندن يعني كان انا في لندن ابو خالد برضو
موقف ثاني مهم للاشخاص اللي ما كانوا
يؤمنون بقصه ام بي سي وما كانوا يتوقعون
انها
يقولون اجتهاد شباب صغار قاعدين يعني
يلعبون من اللي اقلك
انه في صحفي خضرم ما هو شخص عادي كتب عنكم
تقرير وش القصه واذا ما قلت اسمه
لا اقول اسمه افتخر فيه استاذي وتعلمت منه
يعني كثير بس كان الاستاذ عثمان الامير
وكان رئيس تحرير الشرق الاوسط
عثمان يقول كذا
فانا ضحكت يعني ضحكت لا لا والله بالعكس
ضحكته ورجعت لندن راحت عثماني يعني
عرفت طبعا
حتى ايام التحضير يعني تعرفت عليه وكذا بس
يعني ما في علاقه قويه كانت بيننا فرحت
المسيته يعني وقد لا اسمع انت الحين تقول
هذولا ما يفهمون ترى انا ايد كلامك الحين
انا فعلا هذا الموضوع جديد علي لكن انت
بما انك سبقتنا فيها المجال احتاج انك
تعلمني من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه انا
احتاج علاقاتك بعد انت تعرف ما شاء الله
الناس
وما قصر والله يعني شهاده
عثمان ما ابدا ما كان يتعامل مع الام بي
سي مثل ما يتعامل مع الشكلاست والابحاث
انه مشروع وطني
وطبعا يعني عثمان
بالقياده كمان
بتوجيه من سيدي الملك سلمان الله يحفظ
اللي كان مهتم كثير بالاعلام يعني وكان
عامل الشرق الاوسط بنفس الدرجه ويعطيهم
نفس الاهتمام ويجيني منه اتصالات ذاك
الوقت مثل ما يجي عثمان او الاستاذ عبد
الرحمن راشد بعدين
الاخرين يعني
فكان حريص جدا على موضوع الاعلام السعودي
بشكل عام يعني فاحنا نعتبره هو
الاب الروحي لنا كلنا
ويمكن من اللحظات الفارقه على على يعني
حسب ما وصفت الانت في مرحله لندن عشر
سنوات هذه موضوع من سيربح المليون هذا
البرنامج الظاهر كان نقطه تحول في ام بي
سي صحيح هو بدايه الام بيمكانيات على قدنا
وكذا فيعني كنا معتمدين كثير على المكتبه
صالح كامل الله يرحمه اللي في الشركه
العربيه
وسوينا اتفاق مع التلفزيون المصري اخذنا
منهم بعد من مكتبه التلفزيون المصري بعض
الاعمال اللي عندهم
واخذنا عدد كبير من الافلام العربيه
القديمه يعني
المكتبه يعني
فكنا يوميا بعد نشره الاخبار عندنا فيلم
عربي
سبع ايام بالاسبوع فيلم عربي بعد في
المستهره كل يوم يعني وهذا كان هو
الاعلانات كلها تيجي عليه هو الاساس
بالاعلانات بدينا انا اشرح لي اياها واحد
انطوان شويري الله يرحمه شرح لي اياها قال
لي اول اعلانات جت في الام بي سي كانت
ميزانيتها ماخوذه من اشرطه الفيديو اللي
كانوا يعلنون فيها المعلنين ذاك الوقت
للناس اللي يستاجرون افلام الفيديو او
يشترون
اشرطه
هذه الميزانيه جت منهم ما جت من القنوات
التلفزيون الحكوميه لانه ام بي سي ما
تعتبر عندها نسب مشاهده عاليه عشان
الستلايت الدش لانه ما عدد محدود اللي
اللي يشوفونها
فالفيلم العربي نفعنا في الاول بس طبعا
بعد ما انتشرت الام بي سي واصبح يعني دخلت
هنا على على
الطاق اوسع من المشاهدين
الفيلم العربي خلاص يعني استهلك وبعضها
اعيد يعني اكثر من مره
فبدانا خلاص نخطط على انه نعمل برامجنا
وندخل على يعني على الثقيل على القولون
بالانتاج بالصرف يعني
سيربح مليون كان نقله ما في شك يعني في
وقتها
ملك سلمان الله يحفظك كان يتابع
البرنامج ذاك الوقت
ودائما يسالني مثلا اذا وقف لانه هو يجي
مثلا ثلاثه شهور او اربع شهور بعدين نوقفه
فتره ويرجع فكان دائما اذا شفته
ومتى يرجع او اذا فاتح حلقه يقول ارسل لي
اياها فكان يتابع يعني تعرف ما شاء الله
الله يحفظها ويمكن المرحله هذيك ايضا كان
فيها
موضوع الارتفاع التكاليف ولسه احنا في
البدايات فانت قدمت معامله او قدمت طلب
رسمي على حكومه المملكه على مدى وزراء
لطلب دعم صحيح وش قصه هذا الدعم
ووعدني قال لي انا بعرض كنت تخسرون انتم
صح ايه
يعني كان في دخل بس كنا نخسر يعني صرف
قدمت انه نبي يعني
دعم على شكل تسهيلات على شكل
صله قروض مع البنوك اي شيء يعني اللي
يوصلنا
لانه المشاريع اللي مثل هذه فيها تكامل مع
الحكومه يعني انت اليوم
مثل ما قلنا قبل شوي يعني كم اللي كان
يصرف على
الصحفيين اللي بره هذولا كم اللي كان دوله
تدعم فيه جهات خارجيه اليوم مثلا دوله مثل
امريكا اليوم يعني
معلنه الان انه انه دعموا شركات مثل
امازون مثل تسلم مثل سبيسكس
جمع اوباما كل الشركات الكبيره
الاعلاميه مثل جوجل ومثل الفيسبوك
وصار في تسهيل المحكوميه لهم كبيره يعني
وهذا جزء من
عمل الحكومات في العالم يعني
الحقيقه ما قصروا من هالناحيه معنا وقتها
وهذا اصلا كان بان اكثر على موضوع العربيه
يوم جهه العربيه في المرحله اللاحقه يعني
في 2003 كمان اكثر يعني واعتمد الدعم
تسهيلات تسهيلات اه اوكي اتذكر سولفت معك
ابو خالد على اقسى مرحله في الثلاثين سنه
اصعب لحظه عليك في الثلاثين سنه فقلت لي
عن حدث صار في هالفتره فتره لندن اللي هو
موضوع الكيبل الارضي في السعوديه اللي ولد
في نفس تلك المرحله 97 في 95 وش هالسته
وليش ما نجح
اوكي الحين بعد الام بي سي طلعت الام بي
سي مع القناه الفضائيه المصريه كانوا هم
اول قناتين موجوده في
هذه القصه
الشريف كان وزير الاعلام الله يرحمه مصري
رحنا له عشان ناخذ منهم موعد الام بي سي
وكذا فاتذكر جايب واحد جنبه كان يسجل
زي محضر اللقاء وكذا وكنت انا وصالح كامل
الله يرحمه
فكان يسالني
طبعا مجاملات ومدري ايش وبعدين هذا اللي
يكتب مسؤول في مصر نعم وحنا على اساس نبغى
منهم مواد يعني ولسه ما بعد طلعت
فهذا اللي جنبه بعد شوي صار هو يسال اسئله
واسئله تقنيه بحته يعني طيب كيف حتوصلون
للناس هذه الستلايت من وين ايش نوع الدش
الاستقبال شنو فانا شوي حسيت الرجال هذا
طلع مهندس طلع هو اللي مسؤول عن عن البث
وعن الستلايت
شهرين ما اخذنا اللي مطلعين خبر تعرف مع
الاعلام المصري والضجه اللي انه القناه
الفضائيه المصريه اول قناه فضائيه عربيه
تطلع طبعا هم الماده جاهزه عندهم فقط اخذ
القناه الاولى المصريه حطوها على على
وقالوا اول قناه عربيه يعني بس المعلومات
كلها
لانها مختلفه اذا انت تشغلين عليها اي لا
لا احنا في شيء اسمه كان موجود عند عربسات
ما كانوا يستخدمونه الحكومات عرفت اول من
انتبه له احنا اول من انتبه له تقنيا يعني
اخذناها ان كان فيها قناتين بس فاحنا
اخذنا وحدهم راح واخذوا الثانيه فاخذوا
المعلومات مننا وقتها
بس انا معك بالعكس انا كنت كان ودي قنوات
اكثر تطلع لانه هذه خلي الدش ينتشر اكثر
والناس تشوفنا
لانه مهما كان يعني برامج تلفزيون المصري
يعني مختلفه شوي وايش علاقه هذه بموضوع
الكيبل اوكي لا الكيبل هذا بعدين الكيبل
العام 95
انا شرحت الفكره الملك فهد الله يرحمه
يمكن بال 94
قبل ما يمرض في 95 الله يرحمها شرحت
الفكره وايدها تماما
الفكره انه يكون في مثل انا اخذت احنا
اخذناه من سكاي في بريطانيا في
بريطانيا اللي اخذوها سكاي وصار كل اي احد
يبغى يدخل للكيبل في بريطانيا ما يقدر الا
عن طريق سكاي
فعندك يعني
بوابه واحده للبلد
وشرحتها الملك فهد وقد ما حنا ودنا نعمل
شيء مثل هذا هنا
رجع الموضوع البث الارضي يمكن تقول له
يقول لا يعني مو وقته كذا قال لي اوكي هنا
ممكن لان هنا الناس تدفع عشان تشترك اللي
يبغى يشترك
ما هي مفتوحه للناس كلهم فاقتنع بالفكره
ورحنا وقعنا مع وزاره الاعلام ومشينا في
المشروع وكان مشروع عظيم الحقيقه يعني
في عام 97 اعتقد كلمني وزير الاعلام اعتقد
كان الوقت قال لي ترى كان في جلسه المجلس
الوزراء
احنا يوم يوم اتفقنا مع وزاره الاعلام هم
قالوا احنا اللي بنشرف على يعني يكون في
نوع من الرقابه على وش القنوات وايش
المحتوى اللي يدخل الكيبل
وافقنا طبعا لان هذا من حق اي دوله يعني
حتى سكاي على فكره في عليها
يعني نوع من
تحديدش المواد اللي تكون موجوده وكذا حسب
طبعا قوانينهم
في يوم كلمني فؤاد الفارسي بعدها بسنتين
واحنا خلاص بدينا وانتشرنا ما عاد باقي
الا نضغط الزر ونبدا البث يعني
قال لي ترى كان في اجتماع المجلس الوزراء
واخذ قرار انه
الاوربت
والشوتايم تستثنى من الكابل ويقدروني
باجهزتهم
يسوقونها مثل ما انتم تسوقون الكيبل طبعا
يدخلون تحت رقابه وزاره الاعلام قال لي لا
زي ما هم هم كانوا موجودين في السوق اصلا
فقال لهم يستمرون زي ما هم يعني يستمرون
وانتم تعملون
هذه القنوات اللي موجوده
والماده مراقبه
ونفس الافلام ممكن تطلع هنا او هنا بدون
رقابه مين بيجي يشترك عندي يعني هنا انضرب
المشروع
واصلا الفكره كلها انتفت يعني
فوصلنا الى خلاص سيتلمنت انه نلغي المشروع
طبعا
يعني كثير اثر الحقيقه الموضوع لانه هذا
كان يعني معطينا شوي مثل يقول النور اللي
اخر النفق
بعدها
رب ضاره النافع طبعا
صار عندنا حنا مواد
محتوى اشتريناه للكيبل
وعقود مع استديوهات بره في امريكا وفي
هالغيرها
عشان تبثونها من خلال الكيبل للمشتركين بس
الحين صارت
ليبلتي علينا صارت
عقود موقعين ملزمين فيها
فوالله ارسلنا مجموعه من عندنا راحوا
يقعدون مع كل واحد من هذولا ويشرحون لهم
ايش اللي صار
وقالوا لهم شوفوا نعطيكم خيارين الخيار
الاول انه تسمحوا لنا نبثها مفتوح يعني
اعلانات مثل الام بي سي هذا خيار خيار
الثاني
انه نلغي العقود وندخل المحاكم لانه
حقوقها اشتريت لتمثل المشتركين
والحقوق ما هي موقع على خمس سنين يعني
مثلا الالتزام انك تستمر كل سنه تدفع خمس
سنوات
فمعظمهم طبعا اعتقد كلهم معظمه موافقوا
وما عاد اظن
اللي فقط بالثوم بالكيبل ما يبون ماده
موادم تطلع
بس معظمه موافقوا
من هنا طلعت القنوات اللي طبعا بعدين
انتقال دبي كل هذا القصه
يعني تبلورت بعد الانتقال لدبي
ام بي سي 2 وام بي سي اكشن ام بي سي ماكس
ام بي سي 4 ام بي سي 3 كل هذا المحتوى كان
للكيبل بالاساس كامل لاعاده نشره بث
المحتوى اللي انتم شايفين فيه ايوه صارت
فرصه انكم تفتحون القنوات الاربعه الباقيه
وسرعت
البريكيفين يعني سرعت انه نوصل نقطه
الربحيه
صار عندهم خمس قنوات
ممتازه لموضوع من لندن الى دبي انت ذكرت
لي انه في اكثر من دوله كانت تبغى
تستقطبكم حتى الظاهر امير عسير كان يحاول
يستقطبكم فليش اخترت دبي وش اللي صار
وقتها لا
القرار انه لندن غاليه فعلا غاليه وذاك
الوقت
ضريبه تدفعون صح الضرائب كانت توصل 40% بس
لذاك الوقت الام بي سي خلص نعرفه ومبثت
ارضي في دول مثل البحرين والكويت وفي
المغرب ما عاد صار في الخوف يعني صار عندك
عندك
للمحتوى
وسياسه القناه سياسه
التوجه العام فصار في قبول من معظم الدول
العربيه اللي حكينا معهم احنا
وقتها حكينا نتذكر مع
رفيق الحريري الله يرحمه في لبنان كان
مرحب جدا
بالعكس يعني كان يحاول قوه انه يجيبنا على
لبنان
والشيخ محمد بن راشد طبعا في دبي وحكينا
مع البحرين بوقتها
مصر يعني
ما كانوا
متحمسين كثير ولكن ما قالوا لا يعني ندرس
ونشوفهم
فطبعا مصر كان فيها ميزه واحده بس انه
ارخص وفيها
عدد الناس اللي نحتاجهم من
العاملين في المجال الفني نفسه يعني فكانت
هذه هي ولبناني لحد ما فيهم هذه ميزه فيهم
يعني
السعوديه ذاك الوقت تعرف كان كان وقت
في حرب مع الارهاب ومع المشاكل اللي كانت
صايره ومع هذا الامير خالد الفيصل اتذكر
الله يطول عمرك كان مره قال لي قال لي
خلاص تعالوا عندنا في ابها كان هو في ابها
ذاك الوقت
وابد انا جريده الوطن جبتهم هناك ونسوي زي
مثل يعني بطلب اذن انه نعمل مثل المدينه
الاعلاميه في ابها
وتكونون حتى تتذكر ينكت كان يقول يقول ترى
اللي من عرب الشمال ما جوابها بيناسبهم
انه مثل لبنان وسوريا والاردن ترى
بس لا يعني ما يعني ما كانت طبعا جديه لكن
الحقيقه
اكثر اثنين كان الشيخ محمد بن راشد الله
يطول عمرك كان حريص جدا وارسل
مجموعه لندن كانوا يستمعون مع كل رؤساء
الاقسام ومع طبعا
يشوفون احتياجاتهم طلباتهم كمبري اكتف من
هالناحيه ورفيق الحريري كان حريص في لبنان
رفيقه
كان مناسبه مرور عشر سنوات في 2001
فقال لي تعال انا انا بستضيفكم في بيروت
وحذر الحفل وعملنا مرور عشر سنوات
وش اللحظه اللي حسمت الموضوع وقلت يعني
خلاص حننتقل دبي
اول شيء لبنان
تركيبه لبنان
من الاحزاب المختلفه والطوائف المختلفه
اللي فيها ما فيها ضمانات يعني اتذكر رفيق
الله يرحمك كان يقول انا انا ضمانتكم يعني
وشبنا وش صار بعدين يعني
من الناحيه من ناحيه السكيورتي يعني ما
كانت
خير الخير الافضل
والحقيقه الشيخ محمد بن راشد كان كان يعني
قالوا وش تبون بس يعني حتى انا اتذكر قدره
الحين عرفت احتياجاتنا انت وش تبي منه قال
ابيكم تنجحون اذا نجحتوا انا انجح
من الحوار كان لماح انه يتكلم عن مخاوفك
قبل ما انت تتذكرها او اشياك هو يسبق قبل
ما
يجيك ضغط من احدى الدول على برنامج ولا
على خبر في الاخبار او على مدري ايش
كيف حتى التعامل معه فسر هو اللي بادر
يعني يقول ابدا هذه احنا مسويين مدينه
اعلاميه حره هذه فريزون وهذه ما نتدخل
فيها ولا في السياستها ولا يعني كلام كلام
حقيقه مقنع جدا يعني اتذكر برضو ضمن
الزياره كان شفت لك مقابله قبل سبع ثمان
سنوات كنت اتكلم على موقف انه
رحت مع الشيخ محمد لمناسبه مع المجتمع
الاماراتي وكان في واحد يطلب وساطه في
لو تحكي لنا الموقف هذا هذا كنا عازمنا
على الغداء الشيخ محمد ومر علي
معالي محمد القرقاوي
للغداء للقصر قصر الشيخ محمد احنا جيناك
مرتين او ثلاث قبلها يعني
البر بنروح
يوم رحنا وصلنا
خيمه كبيره
نزلت كان الشيخ محمد
بن زايد
الله يحفظه والشيخ محمد بن راشد موجودين
ومن اهل المنطقه يعني من
القبائل الموجوده في المنطقه عندهم عرس
حاضرين عرسهم يعني
احنا جلسنا جاء واحد حكى الشيخ محمد بينه
وبينه كذا بعدين رفع صوت الشيخ محمد بن
راشد وقال اخوان انا
برد على هذا الرجال بس ابيكم كلكم تسمعون
انه الرجال يتوسط الواحد من عيالهم
احتك في في بنات او في في احد الاسواق في
دبي
وانا اقول لكم الحين هذا الموضوع ترى ما
اقبل فيه وساطه اللي هو التحرش انه يعني
احد يعني
تفتح
للعالم
فقال انا هذا الموضوع ما اكبر فيه واسطه
حتى لو كان احد من عيال الرجال هذه ياشر
على الشيخ محمد بن زايد
الرجاله او من عيالي انا
فتذكر يعني هذا موقف كان صراحه بالنسبه لي
يعني يعني تعرف تشوف انه وين رايح الشيخ
محمد بدبي بعد بعدها بعد هذه واخذنا على
ماكيت كبير في ابراج الامارات بالدور اعلى
دور عندها مكتب الشيخ محمد
ودخلني على
الماكيت كبير
ولوحات وصور خرائط وعلى الجدران
والراني النخلات هذه اللي بيسويها
والمشاريع كلها ما كانت موجوده ذاك الوقت
ولا نعرف عنها ولا اعلنت
لكن
كان كان عند فيجن ما في شك يعني اقتنعتو
وقررتوا خلاص
نروح المناسبه ذي انا خلاص احنا نقل يعني
بدانا فيه يعني كانوا معطينكم دورين
ومحددين لكم عدد معين وبعدين
محمد القرقاوي المدينه الاعلاميه كان فيها
ثلاث مباني قال خذوا المساحه اللي تحتاجون
فتذكر التيم اللي معنا اخذوه قالوا نحتاج
دورين من احد المباني
وقتها لانه نسبه اللي انقله معنا من لندن
لدبي كانت قليله
كثير من اللي
الانجليزي اللي كانوا معنا اجلسوا في لندن
يعني كلهم يلقون يعني هناك وظائف ما كان
عندهم مشكله يعني مو مضطرين للنقل
ودبي ما كانت مثل دبي اليوم يعني
العرب بعضهم اجلسوا لانهم
هذه فرصه لهم ياخذون الجنسيه
والجواز فالجواز يحتاج لضمن خمس سنوات او
شيء فاللي ما كملوا المده قالوا لنا
رايحين الجواز هم علينا من ننقل معكم
تقريبا كم في الميه يمكن خمسين ستين في
الميه اللي انقله وكان يكفيهم دور دورين
بس انت كنت فانا قلت لهم لا يعني احنا ما
جينا دبي عشان نبقى على العدده وعلى
القناه ذي كنا طبعا بدانا موضوع
بدات يعني
ناخذ المبنى كله
مبنى بالكامل وانطلقت بالكامل المرحله هذي
احنا قلنا صار فيها التوسع للقنوات
لاستخدام المحتوى اللي تدبسته فيه من
الكيبل وبعدين بدا موضوع الدخل يزيد
وصارت هناك لحظه تاريخيه انه لاول مره
تحققون نقطه التع
وتزامن معها بالمصادفه انه الدعم بدا ايضا
يتوقف من الحكومه
احنا على فكره
اول ما نقلل دبي بدا الصرف يقل عدد
الموظفين نزل ترى يعني حتى غير الموضوع
الضرائب في لندن احنا جايب نص موظفين يعني
الصرف قل كثير
على طول يعني ماخذ وقت معنا ترى انه انه
يصير وهنا ما احتجنا احنا تسهيلات زياده
من الحكومه فيعني
وقفنا هنا
ابدا
لما صارت العربيه هي اللي رجعنا فتحنا
الموضوع مره ثانيه على قصه العربيه بس بعد
سنتين من دبي 2003 وش قصه العربيه
العربيه كان اللي فتح الموضوع معي كان
الامير عبد المجيد الله يرحمه
وقتها كنا في مناسبه عنده في البيت
فقال لي ليش الحين
الجزيره يعني البي بي سي ذاك الوقت
العربيه
القنوات
كانت تهاجم المملكه بشكل
يعني
مبالغ فيه يعني
فقال يعني انتم عندكم القدره وعندكم
الفريق اللي ممكن يعمل قناه انا لكن احنا
ماني بنهاج احد ولا نبي بس نبي على الاقل
في حقائق إيه تظهر للناس وهذا دوركم وكذا
فانا كنت قلت له شوي متخوف من هذا المشروع
لانه غير تجاري غير مربح القنوات
الاخباريه في العالم يعني عندك انواع يعني
عندك البي بي سي مثلا في بريطانيا في
اليوم ضريبه كل واحد في بريطانيا مو بس
البريطاني حتى انت اذا ساكن في بريطانيا
تدفع اسمها ضريبه بي بي سي نعم فانت تدفع
للبي بي سي الضريبه سنويه يعني غصبا عليك
شفتها ما شفتها مجرد عندك تلفزيون في
البيت اسمها ضريبه هذه بريطانيا مثلا في
امريكا عندك
ام بي سي قنوات الاخباريه كلها عن طريق
الكيبل فهي بريسولد يعني داخل الكابل
ضامنين الان كم يعني مع كام كاستو مع
براذرز اللي يكون الكابل اللي اللي ياخذها
في دخل بغض النظر عن الاعلانات طبعا في
اعلانات بس هم دخلهم الاساسي من
الاشتراكات يعني
وهي اساسيه في كل كيبل حتى في اوروبا
فانك تيجي تحطها على على نفس نظام الجزيره
هنا مثلا بث مفتوح للناس خصوصا الناس ما
تدفع هنا على الاداه كنا يعني متخوفين منه
صراحه من هالناحيه
بعدين راح الموضوع يوم جاء بعدها بفتره
كلموني من الديوان قالوا
تجي تقابل الملك عبد الله
الله يرحمه رحت قبلته قال لي علمني قال لي
عبد المجيد علمني عن مشروعكم
يعني كيف ممكن ينعمل قناته وكذا فشرحت له
طيب بس ترى انا ما ودي انها تنعمل
بالطريقه هذه مثل مثل اللي عمله القطرين
او غيره من المشاريع انا افضل انه نعرض
على اصدقائنا في الدول العربيه
اللي يرغب يدخل شريك في المشروع انا نرحب
فيه
وحتى ان شاء الله لو يدخل بواحد في الميه
مو بلازم يدخل بنسبه كبيره لان انا ما
ابيهم يشوفون ان هذا المشروع ضد احد او
حنا نعمله يعني متوجه
يعني باي درجه معينه او نبي يعني
نهاجم في احده
فبتسم مع انه يعني داخليه ماني مقتنع
صراحه العرب ما عمره مجتمعوا على شيء يعني
بيجتمعون على قناه بعد وين بديره كيف بكره
بيصير هالبورد وكيف يعني
تستمعوا ابشر
ورحت قبلت تتذكر يعني مجموعه منهم ذاك
الوقت يعني الشيخ صباح
واتذكر قال لي وش الاستثمار وكذا قلت
والله احنا حاطين مبدئيا عشره في الميه
الحصه يعني على عشر حصص يعني على اساس
ممكن عشر دول لو اول يعني كلن ياخذ اللي
قال لي ابي حصتين انا انا ادخل بعشرين في
الميه وكان وزير الاعلام وقت الشيخ احمد
الفهد كم معنا الاجتماع
ما قصرت
ودك تذكر رحت على عبد الله صالح في اليمن
وقتها
وشرحت للموضوع قال لي
هاله خشمي بلغ الملك عبد الله انا اول
واحد يعني
المملكه تدفع ههه
ورحت نزلت كذا واحد والرفيق الحريري طبعا
رحب كثير كان هو رئيس وزراء لبنان وقتها
انه يدخل فيها
يعني
معمر
يوم انا انا طلبت موعد يعني
صادفت انه الموعد
يمكن انه بعد قمه شرم الشيخ
قمه شرم الشيخ صار فيها الاحتكاك بين
الملك عبد الله وبين معمر
فانا رحت على الموعد يعني مبرمج وكذا وكنت
في دبي وما كنت يعني حتى ما كنت يعني مركز
على موضوع اللي صار يعني
فيوم رحت اثر الرجال معبي على المملكه
وعلى الملك عبد الله
ويوم خلصنا الاجتماع العربيه والعربيه طيب
طيب بس يا اخوان لو سمحتوا اطلعوا اللي
معي كلهم قعدت أنا
فجلست انا وياه لحالنا
طلع بالكلام تماما عن قصه العربيه وقصه
القناه ودخل في مواضيع الموضوع الخلاف
اللي بينه وبين الملك عبد الله فانا قلت
لها هذا مو اختصاصي وانا ما اعمل في
الحكومه السعوديه ولا لاي علاقه فيها
الموضوع
ويمكن احسن هذا يكون في
قناه مشتركه بينكم سواء من خلال سفيره ومن
خلال الوزراء اللي يتعملون معكم
وطلعت من عنده وحنا طلعنا ندور السلامه
وتشكلت المفروض انها قناه العربيه لتجمع
كل هذولي لكن فعليا ما صار شيء انتوا
انطلقتوا بتمويل من تمويل ذاتي وبديتو
2003 هي بدت تمويل من الام بي سي البدايه
وعلى اساس كان المفروض انه الكويت معنا
الكويت صار في خلاف بسيط في بدايه البث
كان
بدا
الغزو
الامريكي على العراق
كانت زامنه انطلاق العربيه مع بدايه الغزو
كنا احنا ماخذين التسميه اللي الام
المتحده اطلقتها انه الغزو
غزو العراق غزو العراق
فالكويت كانوا يسمونه حرب التحرير يعني
تحرير العراق من صدام ومن
قالوا لنا لا لازم تغيرون العنوان انكم
تخلونه حرب التحرير
على الكويت يعني وانا ما الوم الكويت طبعا
من اللي مروا فيه يعني ولكن احنا ما نقدر
نطلع خارج
السياق اللي الامم المتحده
فصار هذا الخلاف بعدين قالوا بننسحب
الموضوع وانتهى الموضوع يعني كمل وصوت فقط
السعوديه هي اللي خلف القناه في البدايه
الام بي سي يعني
يمكن من اللحظات المهمه ايضا اقصد لحظه
معنويه مهمه في مرحله ام بي سي دبي انها
اقيمت مناسبه انت دعيت دكتور غازي القصيبي
الله يرحمه عندك في البيت بحضور مجموعه
وقال
لما كنت سفير في لندن
جاء شاب صغير
يحمل معه حلم كبير
وتكلم بشكل يعني في اشاده كبيره
لتجربتكم
واتذكر يعني كتب مقال على هذا الموضوع
ومنها اخذتنا
السالفه هذه
لا ابدا هو الدكتور غازي كان وزير وقتها
وكان جايب في مهمه رسميه في ابوظبي
وطبعا بين الصداقه وبين
عشره ايام لندن فكلمنا قبل ما يجي قال انا
بروح لابو ظبي بس بالليل بجي اتعشى معكم
وجمعنا نفس الشله تقريبا اللي كانوا في
لندن كانوا موجودين استمتعنا معاه الله
يرحمه كانت هذه اخر مره شوفوا فيها بعدها
سافر لامريكا
وفي نفس هذيك الفتره برضه بدات موضوع
شاهد 2011 ل 2008
نعم اه بدايه شاهد كانت 2008
شاهد مفتوح كان كان اللي يسمونه اللي هو
مواد التلفزيون نفسها يلقونها الناس له
اللي فاتها عمل مسلسل وبرنامج ويقدر يشوفه
في فتره لاحقه
بدانا 2008
وذاك الوقت ما كان يعني صحيح نتفليكس كانت
بداياتها
والتقنيه بدات تظهر لكن
المدفوع
انه
الانترنت ما كان بالقوه اللي صار فيها
بعدين يعني
ترددنا في مساله انه يكون مدفوعه وانه
نستثمر ونحط فيه راس مال مع انه انا اتذكر
في مجلس اداره الام بي سي يمكن على 2011
كان معانا والله يمكن 2012
كان من اعضاء مجلس الاداره ذاك الوقت محمد
عبد اللطيف جميل وخالد الملحم كانوا
يميلون الى الاستثمار في شاهد المدفوع
يعني كان نتفليكس باديه تظهر على السطح
وكانت ام بي سي تدفع تعطينا ارباح يعني
ذاك الوقت فكانوا يقولون بدل ما توزع
ارباح على الشركاء وحطها في في شاهد ذاك
الوقت
الاداره ما كانوا متحمسين كثير الصحيح
يعني وقتها
بدانا الاستثمار في شاهد 2020
12 سنه عشان تؤمنون بالموضوع ها لا هو لان
الانترنت يعني وصل بالشكل يعني خلص يعني
صار في ثقه انك تحط يعني ثقل عليه ممكن
تغيرت سلوك الناس
وعرفتهم اكثر على هذا ولا لا وطلع امازون
وطلع يعني بدات
تكون اوضح
2020 بعد يعني
كنا محظوظين انه بدانا
مع بدايه
مع بدايه كورونا كان احنا بدانا في
جانيوري وكورونا
صارت في اظن شهر ثلاثه او اربعه من نفس
السنه ايه
انغلاق في
معظم الدول العربيه
وهذا
ساعد في انتشاره الاشتراكات
وشاهد بشكل
ممتاز مره بالنسبه لنا يعني ذكر في رمضان
بعد من 100 الف في رمضان وصل مليون على
طول يعني في اول
خمس شهور يعني كنت واحد منهم انا اول مره
اشتركت ودفعت كانت في رمضان
2020 الوقت الجاي كانت لحظه الانطلاقه
لشاهد وحنسولف شوي عن شاهد بس انا برجعك
للتسعينات واقول لك ضيعتها 200 مليون
دولار
هذه مشاهد نوعا ما وش قصه كلمتين مليون
يضاع هذا
في احنا ذيك الايام اشترينا اليونايتد
بريس انترناشونال من بنك
في بدايه 92 الى 91 في اخر واحد تسعين
بدايه 92
مفلسه وكانت مفلسه في المحكمه ولقينا فرصه
وباربعه مليون دولار يعني ولا شيء يعني
وقتها طبعا بعدين اكتشفنا في وراها
الايبلات كبيره يعني
انه الموظفين كانوا مرتبطين باليونان
واحنا ما كنا فاهمين قصه
هذه
الاتحاد العمال في امريكا وكيف يشتغل وانك
ما تقدر تفصل احد
كان في عدد كبير من المكاتب الصغيره في كل
قريه في امريكا وكل مدينه لليوبياي فيها
موظفين ما تقدر تفصلهم طبعا هذول عبء كبير
على على التشغيل على الشركه المهم انه في
في البيت الابيض في امريكا عندهم
اي رئيس امريكي جديد
صحفيين البيت الابيض يدعونه في مناسبه على
العشاء في حفل يسمونه برد ايرن كلوب هذا
الحفل يجي الرئيس يحضر واللي اللي يكون
يدعي للحفل وهو اللي يكون
رئيس
الصحفيين البيت الابيض هي بالنيابه كل كل
واحده من وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
يحطون المندوبهم في بيت الابيض يكون رئيس
الفتره معينه بعدين يجي اللي بعده واللي
بعده كذا يتناوبون عليها
على حظنا بالصدفه ذيك المره كانت هيلين
توماس
مراسله اليوبياي في البيت الابيض هي رئيسه
الصحفيين البيت الابيض فهي بالعرف تدعي
رئيسه هي اللي انا كان ذاك الوقت
يجلس جنب الرئيس
فرحت حضرت الحفل كانت فرصه طبعا بقت جنب
الرئيس كلينتن
وجلست وقعدت سولفت
طبعا هم معطينه عني خلفيه وعن الام بي سي
واليوبياي وكذا
فقال لي انا مستغربة أيش استثمر بالشغلات
هذه خصوصا انك توك باديه جديد كانت اول
سنه لنا يعني
الان كان اول
للاستخدام العسكري الان صار
للاستخدام العامه يعني للناس وهذا هو
الاعلام الجديد وهو
المستقبل
كان يعني يشرح شرح كامل يعني كان هو
بالنسبه لهذا هذا مشروع يعني هم طبعا من
الانتخابات هو كان يتكلم عنه
اللي اطلقه وقتها
وقتها ياهو
كانوا طالبين
منهم ياخذون اسم يحطونه على صفحه الاخبار
في يهو
ويدفعون مقابلها مليونين دولار عباره عن
اسهم فيه
رئيس اللي كان ماسك
العرض طلب اكثر او شيء زي كذا
ياهو طبعا ذاك الوقت ياهو وامريكا اون
لاين قبل قبل جوجل وقبل فيسبوك وقبل كلهم
ياهو ومركن اون لاين طلعوا مثل الصاروخ
اللي يسموها
فكل سنه انا اشوف المليونين دولار هذي كل
مره تطلع 200 مليون على
200 مليون لازم نفسها اللي كان قيمتها
مليونير
فلو ماخذها
ههه وكان ما خسرنا شيء ترى بس يحطون اسم
نظر من الاداره اللي كانت موجوده وقتها
صراحه رزق ما كتب لك
ونرجع لفتره ام بي سي دبي اللي كانت فيها
العربيه
تتشكل وبدات واخذت خط تحرير ودي افهم مش
طبيعه العلاقه بين ام بي سي والعربيه وش
موقع الحكومه السعوديه في العربيه هل
تدخنتم في التحرير ولا لها التحرير مستقل
وبدي افهم هذه اكثر اوكي
الملك عبد الله الله يرحمه يوم سالني عن
العربيه بعد ما الامير عبد المجيد حكى
معاه وقتها وجلست معه يوم سالني عن
العربيه قال انتم من وين بتجيبون الناس
ومن وين يعني كيف تسوونها
قلت لها انت شوف اخبار الام بي سي قال لي
قلت خلاص شفت هذول اللي عاملين اخبار الام
بي سي ترى نفس غرفه الاخبار هذه هي اللي
بتكون العربيه هم احنا حادينهم ما يسوون
الا كان اول شيء نشرتين بعدين نزلناه الى
نشره واحده لانه حنا قناه منوع بس انا لو
قلت لهم روحوا الان اعملوا قناه ترى ما
حيكون عندهم مشكله يمكن يضيفون بعض
الصحفيين بعض الموظفين زياده بس ما عندهم
مشكله انهم
يعملونها فاذا انت عجبتك اخبار الام بي سي
ترى ما حتكون مختلفه كثير عنها
[موسيقى]
في موقف قال لي
الوزير الدكتور عبد العزيز خوجه يوم كان
وزير اعلام
في مره من مرات كان جالس عند الملك عبد
الله
وطلع على العربيه خبر
مقابله مع عبد الحليم خدام
في ذاك الوقت كان انقلب على
الحكومه وعلى بشار الاسد والحكومه السوريه
وقتها يعني
وطلع الخبر طبعا كان خبر كبير ومجلجل
وعظيم كان ليله راس السنه
فيقول انا كنت في المجلس عند الملك ملك
يتفرج وكلنا نتفرج ورفع الصوت
ولا واحد في المليون ان الملك عارف عن
الموضوع هو يعني يعني الموضوع مرتب يقول
طلعت كلمت حق التلفزيون السعودي خودهم
للعربيه ذا وحطوه عندكم لان هذا مو يعني
موقف دوله لانه موقف دوله يعني موقف قصدي
كبير
فراحوا طلعوها السعودي
يقول ما اخذت الا اثر باحد تكلم مع الملك
وبلغ الملك يقول
وينهب الملك الله يرحمه انت مهبول
خلينا ناخذ موقف ضد بلد عربي ثاني ايش
دخلك في ذا
انا ما اجتهاد واجتهاد خاطر
فيعني الملك الله يرحمه ما كان يعني سؤال
الملك فهد والملك عبد الله ما ينظرون للي
يطلع في الام بي سي او العربيه انه يمثل
راي الحكومه السعوديه يعني التكامل
في شيء
في وجهات نظر في شغلات يعني يهمهم انها
تطلع مثلا نتواصل فيها بعض
المسؤولين
نضرب بالشكل اللائق والمناسب في حال
اخذت مواقف معينه بس ما في شيء اسمه طلع
دوله طلعوا
السعوديه تملك في قناه العربيه ولا لا
وانتم تملكون ومتشغلون لا احنا احنا
العلاقه بيننا تسهيلات بيننا في في حال
انه ما كان في دخل تجاري كافي الفكره كلها
انه الام بي سي والعربيه مستقله تماما
وتجاريه بحته في حال انه توفر الجانب
الدخل التجاري
فليصير انه بعض الاحيان يصير في تسهيلات
الى ان يكون في دخل كافي
عشان تستمر
من اي دعم في اي دعم ما هو ترى اي دعم ما
يمكن تستمر عليه الى الابد
من واجبك انت انه انك في يوم من الايام
توصل الى
الربحيه وتوصل الى انك حتى تكبر من خلال
للتجاري للمشروع في نفسك الفتره الامير
وليد بن طلال بدا قناه الاخباريه لقناه
العرب وكان يعني تموضعها او وصف لها بانه
الجزيره قناه الشعوب العربيه قناه
الحكومات العرب نبغاها في النص كذا كان
يصف التموضع هل هذا تموضع العربيه صحيح
ابدا بالعكس اليوم اليوم العربيه
واصله للشعوب اكثر من اي قناه عربيه ثانيه
اليوم كيف يعني نسب المشاهده نسب مشاهده
العربيه اليوم في العالم العربي اكبر من
اي قناه ثانيه يعني العربيه والحدث حتى
الحدث
احنا يصير عندنا مشكله بعض الاحيان مثلا
اعطيكم مثال يعني مثلا يوم الاحداث
السودان
العربيه كرست كل البث
للسودان مثلا
الاحداث اللي صارت كان في مشكله لانه
الناس تعتمد على العربيه في في تغطيه
الاخبار الاسواق المال
بفتره فتح افتتاح السوق كان يجيناز كثير
من الناس انه طيب الحين رحتوا للسودان وين
احنا وين
نبي نبي العربيه ونبغى التحليل ونبغى
بالعكس العربيه
قناه الشعوب الدرجه الاولى يعني
مرحله ايضا دبي كان فيها التوسع لقنوات
الدول يعني احنا شفنا قنوات التخصص او
المجال اللي هي قناه افلام قناه اطفال هذه
حكينا قصتها لكن ايضا بداتوا في موضوع
قنوات الدول ام بي سي مصر ام بي سي العراق
ام بي سي الفرس او فارس وش السر هذه
الجغرافيا بالنهايه انت
اليوم اليوم
المطلوب انك تكون
اللي يسمونه اللي هي القنوات اللي تبث على
العالم العربي كله
ما عاد صارت
تقدر تنافس القنوات المحليه لان الناس
يبون يبون اخبارهم يبنشؤونهم
ثقافتهم
يعني هذا ما تقدر تعمل على كل الدول
العربيه بنفس الوقت يعني
فرحنا الى انه لا كل منطقه يكون لها
قناه خاصه فيها يعني
ولكن في محتوى يمكن يشكل خمسين او 60%
مشترك يعني اليوم مثلا اذا عملت
مسلسل ضخم او عملت عمل معين بيكون
بيشوفونه كلهم او مثلا برنامج مثل ذا فويس
ولا عرب ايدل
هذه تلقاهم يشوفونه في كل
[موسيقى]
في حقوق نقل الدوله السعودي
وكانت
العقد عشر سنوات
بتكلفه حدود 3.6 مليار ريال على عشر سنوات
طبعا
لكن ما كملته وش اللي صار ابدا هو كان
قرار من الاتحاد السعودي لكره القدم احنا
اتفقنا مع الاتحاد السعودي
قرروا انهم
ينتظرون على التشفير يعني يمدون فتره البث
المفتوح واحنا غير مجدي بالنسبه لنا اليوم
شبر اليوم النقل التلفزيوني في العالم كله
هو نقل مشفر وباشتراكات
لانه الحقوق
اصبحت مرتفعه جدا لشراء شراءها من قبل
الموسات الاعلاميه
اللي صار في العالم بعشره في منطقتنا يعني
منطقتنا
الارتفاع غير منطقي وغير مجدي
انا اتكلم عن الحقوق العالميه يعني مثل
الدورات المهمه الاوروبيه اصبحت اسعارها
فلكيه انا بعطيك مثال
[موسيقى]
اخذته خمس سنوات
اعتقد يمكن من 95 او 96 الى 2000 واحد كنا
ندفع خمسه مليون بالسنه خمس مليون دولار
وهذه للبث في العالم العربي كل العالم هنا
اليوم تعدي 250 مليون دولار طيب ما في اي
ينقلوا من هنا لهنا لو تشوف نفس نفس خلنا
نقول
الشامبيون ليج في بريطانيا خذ نفس الفتره
هذيك والان ما حتشوف التباين في الاسعار
هذا صار فيه
خلنا نقول مال حكومي مال سياسي دخل في
شراء الحقوق
والغى
عمليه التجاريه في الموضوع بالنسبه للدوري
السعودي احنا عملنا دراساتنا على التشفير
في يوم اتخذ القرار من الاتحاد السعودي
بلغه لانه لا نبغى ناجل تشفير
الغينا الاتفاق
وصار في تسويه معهم على
المده او الخساره اللي احنا خسرناها
وانتهى الموضوع وقته ومن ذاك الوقت يعني
المهتمين بالشاي الرياضي يقولون من بعد اي
ار تي ما
جتنا اي لحظه نتابع الدوري حقنا اللي هو
اقوى دوري عربي ومن الاهم عالميا بشكل
مرضي اليوم اسالك كمختص في الاعلام ما هو
رئيس ام بي سي ليش ما احنا قادرين ننجح في
صنع قناه رياضيه توازي اسم المملكه قدرات
المملكه تميز الدوله حقنا حجم المشاهدات
في الدوري والله انا معك في مساله انه انه
حنا سويناه انه ما كانت مرضيه انا اعتقد
البروسبورت كان
نقله نقل ممتاز ولكن طبعا
عاده عشان توصل
للكواليتي اللي اليوم قاعد تشوفها في في
اوروبا وفي حتى بيان
التكاليف تكون اعلى بكثير يعني انت هذه
تعتمد على الاشتراكات وتعتمد على عدد
الاشتراكات كل ما زاد المشتركين كل ما انت
تستثمر اكثر في النقل
بين طبعا
حاله خاصه لانها حكوميه فيعني الحكومه هي
اللي تدفع ما تقدر تقول انه والله هذا
بحكم عدد المشتركين يعني
بس لكن حتى برا
الهدف من من
تحسين النقل وعمل برامج وعمل
تحليل اقوى وجذب محللين بس ما اكبر كل هذا
استثمار
ولازم يكون بالمقابل في اشتراكات فاذا ما
في اشتراكات
يجي هنا القياس على حسب الجهه اللي متولي
النقل يعني اليوم وزاره الرياضه هي اللي
متولي النقل اس سي وطلبوا منه انه يكون في
اشراف من فريق تقني من ام بي سي يعني انه
نرفع مستوى
النقل والحمد لله يعني في الثلاث أربع
شهور الاخيره يمكن لاحظت انه النقل تحسن
كثير
بالفتره اللي فاتت وحيتحسن اكثر في الموسم
القادم يعني بس لازال النقل مفتوح ما هو
مشفر ما هو تجاريا بالمعنى وهذا ما حيساعد
في تطوير النقل التلفزيوني
هنا عاد يرجع للجهه
المموله لعمليه النقل اذا اذا يصرفون اكثر
ممكن يكون افضل لترفع مستوى اكيد يعني
وعندك خيارات يعني انت ممكن مثلا اليوم
اتش دي ولا فور كي ولا
انت تقرر يعني نوع البرامج نوع الضيوف
اللي تجيبهم معلقين كلها يعني قبل ما نقفل
مرحله دبي وننتقل لمرحله رؤيه 2030 نتكلم
على صوره ذهنيه عند المجتمع او عند شريحه
من المجتمع عن ام بي سي بانها القناه اللي
تنشر الانحلال هي مشروع تغريب للمجتمع
المحافظين كانوا ولا يزالون منزعجين من ام
بي سي قناه الاطفال في تحذير شديد منها
وانها اخطر ما يمكن ان يشاهد الانسان هو
قناه الاطفال وحطوا مقطع
لاحد البرامج اللي فيها قوس المطر
يعني اشاعه للشدود او شيء زي كذا فغش
تعليقك على نظره المجتمع المحافظ لام بي
سي
وسلوكها الغير
مرغوب او غير محبب من هذه الشريحه
اول شيء انا اتحفظ على المحافظين او او
المجتمع المحافظ انا اعتقد احنا كنا في
على السنوات طويله في صدام مباشر معدل
الجيم ومع المتطرفين دينيا اكثر من ما هو
المحافظين يعني اليوم
بين واتضح انه الحمد لله البلد كلهم
محافظين وعوائل اللي نعرفهم وهلنا كلهم
محافظين ولكن ما هم متطرفين بالدرجه اللي
كان
كنا نواجه فيها من
المجموعات هذه ولكن برجع شوي وراء للحملات
الحملات ما كانت من جهه واحده كان خلفهم
جيوش من دول
متضرره من الام بي سي ومن العربيه ومن
الاداء تدعم الحملات هذه
وهذا بعدين احنا اكتشفناه من اجهزه يعني
حكوميه بلغونا وين المصادر يعني تجي
وبعضها من نفس اللي حكيت لك عنهم قبل اللي
كانوا يبتزون دول الخليج في الماضي
واصبحوا الان عاطلين وما عندهم شيء بس
عندهم يعني
عندهم
اساليبهم وطرقهم في ركبوا على موجه
السوشيال ميديا الجديده فاي شيء يجي على
ام بي سي او على العربيات تلقاهم
يدعمونا فكانت تجي من من جهات مختلفه يعني
بغض النظر من اللي يبدا الموضوع الباقي
كلهم وراه
بالنسبه اللي تحكي عنها مثلا حقت الرينبو
هذه اللي هي على ام بي سي 3
قوس قزح الحين قوس قزح للاطفال
معظم برامجها في الوان وفيها قوس قزح
وفيها يعني
الطفل
الصغير معظم برامجهم هي اصلا فيها الالوان
ومن الالوان وكذا لكن اللي صار جو غير
الصوت شالوا الصوت الموجود وحطوا صوت
يعيد موضوع المثليه وما اعرف ايش هل
الفيديو هذا ونشروه والعالم
طبعا لا رجعنا حنا للاصل ابدا الصوت واضح
اللي موجود ما له علاقه باللي طلع
الناس تاخذ على اللي تشوفه يعني يعني
اليوم اليوم ما عنده صوت اليوم يقدر يقدر
يجيبك انت عمر بشكلك وبصوتك ويخليك تقول
اللي هو يبيه ويطلع للناس يعني
موضوع
اليوم وقديش ممكن يغير في الشكل وفي الصوت
وفيك تقول كلام وشفناها في مقاطع كثير
وتقنيه موجود وصارت متوفره على مستوى
الناس العاديين بابلكيشن في تلفونها يعني
يقدر يسويها
شوي
خلنا نقول كانوا منظمين
وكانوا
يقومون بحملات مرتبه
ومدروسه
ويضربون في العربيه وفي الام بي سي بطرق
مختلفه شيء مباشر وشيء غير مباشر
وما كانوا كلهم على فكره على شكل لحى
ورجال دين كانوا بالعكس بعضهم يجي على شكل
مهندس وعلى شكل دكتور وعلى شكل ولكن هو ما
ادلت يعني ميوله اخوانيه ميوله س روريه
ميوله ما اعرف ايش يعني على حسب
ويطلعون ويتكلمون
والحمد لله يعني اليوم كله هذه انكشفت
للناس يعني
سر ولكن
في نفس الوقت ترى على فكره ما يعني انهم
تخطي ترى في كثير من الاوقات يكون في خطا
يكون في عمل طلع بشكل
غلط يعني اعطيك مثال انا مثلا
كان في مسلسل اسمه ضحايا حلال عرضوه على
شاهد بالسنه وسنتين
وتذكر كلموني عليه وقته من وزاره الاعلام
انه في عمل وانا ما شفت الصراحه يعني بس
طلبته شفته
طايقت كثير يوم شفته لان النفى
النص اللي كان وافق عليه من شاهد ومن الام
بي سي كان معمول بشكل معين مكتوب بطريقه
معينه
التنفيذ كم شكل مختلف تماما يعني الفكره
كانت انه
وحده تتزوج واحد كبر ولدها كذا مكتوب هذا
اللي كبر ولدها هي حرمه كبيره هي صغيره
المفروض يكون عمره 18 19 سنه
وطالب في الجامعه
اللي نفذ راح جاب وليد عمره 12 سنه او 13
سنه صغير خير
ومرت مرت وطلع العمل ظهرت الحلقه يعني
هذا خطا ما في شك يعني وسحبنا المسلسل في
لحظتها وغيره وشالوا
المشهد واعده وعادوا والتصوير بالشكل
الصحيح يعني
فيصير اخطاء هذا واذا صار نعتذر ونسحب
العمل ونتعامل معاه
توافق قيم المجتمع تصادم قيم المجتمع تحلق
في قيم خاصه فيها ولا الهدف في المجتمع
الخيار انا اعتقد
لميسي بدات في
مشوار
من بدايه التسعينات كانت سابقه اللي نشوفه
اليوم من
منصات مثل نتفليكس ديزني واليوم يعني احنا
نشوف سبايدرمان ديزني اليوم
المثليه
والاطفال مو مو للكبار حتى يعني
الناس لازم تعطيهم محتوى بديل يعني هل
المحتوى البديل هذا
محافظ او او
غير محافظ هذا الموضوع انا اعتقد يحكمون
عليه الناس الناس انا اتكلم عن السواد
الاعظم من الناس مهو على فئه معينه يعني
واحنا راضيين تمام الرضا عن ما في
المجموعه سواء في شاهدوا في القنوات او في
الاذاعه او في كل المنصات اللي اللي احنا
مسؤولين عنها ما عندنا اي تحفظ ابدا
بالعكس انا اعتقد اليوم
الام بي سي هي قناه العائله بالدرجه
الاولى
وهذا احنا نلمسه من المشاهدين بشكل مباشر
الحمد لله خليني اقفل مرحله دبي احنا
خلصنا لندن واحد دبي الحين نفتح مرحله
رؤيه السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين في حراك غير
عادي في السعوديه عموما في ملف الاعلام
والمحتوى
والناشونال شامبيون او الابطال الوطنيين
في قطاعاتهم فمن اكثر من زاويه ام بي سي
صار لها تقاطعات مع الرؤيه وصار لكم لقاء
تاريخي مع الامير محمد
خلينا نتكلم على ام بي سي في مرحله الرؤيه
وش اللي صار في اول لق اء مع الامير وايش
دوركم اليوم في رؤيه السعوديه عشرين
ثلاثين نشوف انا الامير محمد
قبلت اول مره عام 2014
كان رئيس ديوان ولي العهد
الملك سلمان الله يحفظه
جلسه يمكن
ساعه واكثر كان
منطلق فيها
وبنفس الوقت متضايق من بعض
الشغلات اللي اللي كانت موجوده واللي يمكن
كثير كانوا مترددين في التعامل معها
وسمعت عنه سمع مني عن تجربتنا وعن
التوقعات واتذكر وقتها حتى طرح انه طب
انتم ليش ما جيتوا السعوديه يعني فشرحت له
ما وقعت وكذا كان يسجل الله يحفظه
وبنفس الوقت
كان يقول انه حنا يهمنا كثير انكم
تتوسعون انكم تكبرون انكم
نعتبركم
جزء مكمل
الرؤيه اللي حنا
راح نمشي فيها يعني انا انا خل نقول كان
عندي شوي
بيك على الرؤيه قبل ما تصير الرؤيه
2018 لما جلسنا معاه كانت تضحك الصوره
اكثر
وبدانا فعلا عاد نتكلم على ايش القطاعات
ايش
التوجه اللي
منطلقه فيه المملكه
وهذا طبعا بالنسبه لي انا كان صدمه كبير
يعني
الحوار على ايش يعني 2018
السعوديه بلد شاب
فنسبه
الشباب عاليه جدا من الجنسين
وهذول
لهم طلبات يعني
ان كان تتكلم عن
الاعلام الترفيه
كل القطاعات يعني المسرح فعاليات كل
القطاعات تقريبا
وحنا فقط مستقبلين طيب متى حنا نقدر نصدر
متى احنا نقدر على الاقل نكتفي ذاتيا
[موسيقى]
شعبنا في المملكه يعني
بالنسبه لنا يعني كان كان حلم بعيد جدا
وبدانا نلمسه وبدانا نشوف انه انه هذا
ممكن فعلا يتحقق
وهل حسيت انه مهتم يعني يدعم المشروع يوسع
الافاق في وين ممكن نوصل وين ممكن نتخيل
في قطاع الاعلام بشكل عام في ام بي سي
بشكل خاص هل كانت هذه المساحه موجوده ولا
كان نقاش تحديات بس انتقال للرياض انه كيف
ولا كان في 2018 ما كان في كلام حتى عن
الرياض ذاك الوقت يعني كان الكلام لا على
هذه الصناعه كلها يعني وين رايحه وكيف
احنا نكون فاعل فيها
كجزء من الرؤيه انه هذه الرؤيه انه في
طبعا هي الرؤيه على كل القطاعات هذا احد
القطاعات يعني
ابدا يعني انتم طول عمركم تشتغلون قريبين
من الحكومه وعند بينكم وبين الحكومه علاقه
وتكامل
حنا نبغى نطور هالموضوع بشكل اكبر
اعطونا احتياجاتكم كيف ممكن
اوكي طيب الحين اذا لو افترضنا انه هذه
الشركه اليوم
بتكون جاذب
بعض الكفاءات وبعض
المواهب في السعوديه مثلا كيف ممكن حنا
نتوجه الى ان نبتعد بعض البنات الشباب
متخصصات انتم تحتاجونها يعني
مش احتياجاتكم بالضبط يعني المجال وطلع
منها شغلات كثير من ضمن ام بي سي اكاديمي
يعني اليوم ام بي سي اكاديمي
اللي استفادوا من برامج ام بي سي اكاديمي
18 الف
شاب وشاب السعوديه اليوم في احد الاعمال
عندنا اعتقد فيه يمكن 300
اللي اللي
يروحون في
فترات مختلفه يشاركون
في عمليه الانتاج والتصوير
وشغلات ثانيه مثل مكياج مثل
الاضاءه مثل
كل في كل المجالات يعني بس هل بعد هذا
اللقاء كبرت الاحلام ولا صارت ولا وش
رؤيتكم بعدها الجلسه هل اختلفت كثير وشلفت
كثير لانه لانه اليوم صار صار الموضوع
واضح بالنسبه لنا اكثر يعني يعني تخيل انت
انه من عام 91
ومن بدايه الام بي سي من اول يوم واحنا ما
نشوف اللي هنا كذا يعني تمشي انت وتخبط ما
تعرف
تسقع
لا في
بث ارضي قاعد على الدش والدش يمنع وما
يمنع والبحرين وقفت الكويت وقفت المغرب
وقفت يعني ما تدري كيف وضعك بيصير يعني
لندن الكوسبي يرتفع عليك من هنا حتى بعد
ما جينا دبي
برضه الرؤيه ما هي واضحه مئه في الميه
يعني اليوم انت المعلن معك بكره
بدا يطلع منتج اخر اعلامي راح اتجاهله
يعني اليوم حنا نعاني مثلا من
يوتيوب
من من فيسبوك
جوجل من كل
المنصات
الاون لاين
ادبرتايزنج اللي قاعد يسحب من
المحطات التلفزيون والاذاعه والمشاريع
التقليديه
فهي الصوره ما هي دائما
يعني مبسطه واضحه يعني
يعني كل يوم تلقى عندك تحدي مختلف من هنا
ومن هنا
تتعثر وتقوم تتعثر وتقوم بس اليوم اللي
اختلف مع الرؤيه انه لا صار في توجه وصار
في عندك
جهات حكوميه هنا تتعامل معها
عندها خطط طويله الاجل فعلى الاقل انا
اعرف من هنا لين 2030 وش بسوي هذا كفايه
بالنسبه لي وش تبي توصل انت بعد هاللقاء
وش صار الهدف
احنا ان شاء الله هدفنا انه تشوف ام بي سي
من اكبر عشر كيانات اعلاميه في العالم
وتقاطعاتكم مع الرؤيه ومشاريعها يعني شفنا
اتفاقيه مع نيوم في مجال غريب ما تخيلنا
ام بي سي الها علاقه في موضوع الجيمنج
وشفنا فيه مع هيئه الترفيه مسرحيات
ومشاريع
وحفلات وشفنا معي القديه ايضا اتفاقيه مع
الدرعيه ولو تلخصنا وش اهم المبادرات
لليوم ام بي سي قاعده تساهم فيها من خلال
الرؤيه
ام بي سي تشتغل على على عده عده
المحتوى المحتوى
[موسيقى]
تملك
المحتوى او الاي بي مثل ما يسمونه
على
الاتفاقيه اللي عملناها مع اليوم عملنا
شركه
بدانا في اول مشروع اللي هو
عن قصه الف ليله وليله هذا اول مشروع
بدانا فيه بس انا داخلين على مشاريع اخرى
ان شاء الله في
في هذا المجال
الفعاليات
شغالين عليها الان بشكل موسع وشكل اكبر
شغالين على
اي سبورت
الانمي
بيننا وبين القديه شغالين حتى على
الام بي سي لوت
للاستديوهات
المفتوحه هذه مو بس الام بي سي ولا اي احد
بكره يبين سواء من السعوديه من الداخل او
سواء من هوليود وغيرهم اللي يبون ينتجون
في المملكه في قناه انتوا فوق قناه دخلكم
في الاشياء هذه مختلفه الان تعدينا موضوع
قناه الان
الاستراتيجيه الام بي سي شركه اعلاميه هي
ما هي ما هي فقط قنوات يعني احنا بنوصل
حتى الى بعض الايبيز انها تكون ثيم باركس
وملاهي
على على بعض
اللي احنا نملكها
ويمكن مدامنا جينا على اطالها المرحله في
دائما يعني تحفظ على الام بي سي من ناحيه
تمكينها للشباب السعوديين انها قناه
سعوديه بس السعوديين ما هو ممكنين فيها
كموظفين كمنتجين
وهذه دائما تتكرر بشكل مستمر سمع تعليقك
عليها والله الشيف عمر يعني انا اسمع طبعا
اشوف مع بعض الاحيان حملات او غيره على
هذا الموضوع لازم نرجع الاساس يعني الاساس
ام بي سي هي مش السعوديه هي شركه بالمعنى
انها تبث او انها تشتغل داخل السعوديه
للسعوديه ام بي سي اليوم جلوبال يعني شركه
عالميه
عندنا
في الدول العربيه كافه بدون استثناء
متواجده في اوروبا وفي امريكا وفي
استراليا وفي امريكا الجنوبيه وفي اسيا
للمشتركين في شاهد وفي اعمال شاهد اللي هي
موجوده باللغه العربيه والانجليزيه
والفرنسيه ثلاث لغات
فاحنا شركه عالميه
اولا واخيرا لكن
المكان وجودك في المكان اكيد
حيؤثر على الطريقه اللي توظف فيها يعني
اليوم اذا انا موجود في مصر اكيد حيكون
نسبه المصريين عاليه اذا انا موجود في
في دبي مثلا حنشوف مين الارخص او الانسب
او الاكفى في يعني اليوم انا فرض عينت
سعودي وجبته على دبي اشتكلفته علي انا
عشان يجيني في دبي بينما انا عندي يمكن
يمكن اكفى اردني او مصري مثلا او لبناني
وموجود في دبي يعني بس ينتقم من مكان
لمكان هو ساكن وعنده مع اهله ولا لحاله
وتكلفته بتكون اقل عليه من هذه الناحيه
الحين اوكي الان تونا من السعوديه بوجودنا
بالسعوديه ما في شك انه نسبه السعوديين
راح تكون اعلى بكثير وخصوصا بالمشاريع
الجديده لان المشاريع الجديده كلها متجهه
لاعمار
اقل واعمار اصغر والحمد لله السعوديه
اليوم توفر فيها نسبه كبيره من المواهب في
هذه المجالات ومن الكفاءات في المجالات
هذه انا بعطيك مثال انا مثلا على معاناتنا
مع السعوديين في السابق يعني في بدايه في
التسعينات
انا اتذكر شباب سعوديين اشتغلوا معنا ذاك
الوقت من عنف
الهجمات اللي كانت
توجه
من ام بي سي وغيره على فكره حتى التلفزيون
السعودي حتى الجرايد السعوديه اي شيء في
هذا اعلام كله ليبرالي اعلام كله
الى درجه يكفرونه يعني
يستبيح دم ملاك القنوات فتره صحيح هذه احد
[ضحك]
تخيل استقالوا عندنا شباب سعودي مثل الورد
من احسن ما يمكن كانوا كانوا مجتهدين
وكانوا فيه والسبب الاستقاله ضغوط ضغوط من
عوائلهم من اهلهم لانه اهلهم ما تحملوا
اللي يسمعونه يعني يجي في المسجد ويلقى
واحد يخطب ويسب في الاسم كذا فيقول يسب
الام بي سي في المسجد وانت تشتغل فيه انا
ما اكمل لولد فيحط ضغط على ولده نفسي انه
يترك ويتركون في كثير منهم تركوا
اضف على عليها كيف كانوا الجامعات يرفضون
تخصصات اللي حنا كنا نحتاجها ذاك الوقت
سواء في المسرح او في الدراما او في
الاخراج وفي الموسيقى او غيرها الموسيقى
اصلا هذه كلها حرام على بعضها وين ما تروح
يعني
البعثات
الخارجيه كانوا يرفضون تخصصات اللي لها
علاقه في عملنا يعني
كان في محاربه ممنهجه وسيطره ممنهجه في في
قطاعات مختلفه يعني اللي تخرج مواهب
السعوديه فصار المتوفر محدود بالنسبه لكم
الفنانين مثلا الفنانين يعني انا مثلا
اعجبني مع المستشار تركيا للشيخ في تكريم
الفنانين السعوديين القدام مثل بكر الشدي
الله يرحمه محمد العلي طلال مداح محمد
عبده
مسرح
وحفلات تكريم لهم وتاريخهم
هذا شيء عظيم يعني الامير بدر الفرحان في
وزاره الثقافه على رواد المسرح وعلى
الفنون كلها الفن التشكيلي وغيره من
الفنون وتكريمهم والاهتمام فيهم يعني انا
اعتقد هذا ما كنا في يوم من الايام نتخيل
انه نشوفه صراحه يعني من المؤاخذ برضو على
ام بي سي موضوع يعني جوده الانتاج الدرامي
او او المسلسلات وانها ما تمثل المجتمع ما
تشبه المجتمع وكثير منها يعني عليه كل
فعال بس مكرر نفس القصاص الاحداث بشيء ممل
الناس ما تشعر بانها تشوف شيء يوازي حجم
تكلفه الانتاج اللي مثلا متخيل عن مثل هذه
الاعمال ويش تقييمك للجوده الاعمال اللي
تعرض في ام بي سي وفي الاعلام العربي
عموما يعني بسالك انت شفت رشاش اعجبك بس
هو الوحيد اللي عجبني هو المسلسل الوحيد
انا وياك نتفق لانه هذا اللي حتشوف من
الان وطالع ترى يعني هذه النقله من الرشاش
هو بدايه
الانتقال الى المرحله الجايه يعني انه
الانتاج مكان في سبب
ليش رشاش لانه الرشاش ما انطلاقه شاهد
يعني في عندك مشترك اليوم قاعد يدفع فلوس
زي اللي يشتري تذكره للسينما فهذا انا
احترمه هذا لازم اعطيه
بالمستوى اللي هو
اللي هو يتوقع عشان عشان يستمر معي ولا
بيطلع مو قاعد الفرق اول لا الفرق انا انا
احط اعمال للمعلن
المعلن ميزانيته محدوده فانا ما اقدر اجي
افرض على المنتج سواء اللي انا انتج
الاعمال الاول اللي منتج برا يعملها انه
يعملها بتقنيه عاليه غير مجديه طيب
بالاخير كيف انحمشي
الجهاز الاعلامي اللي عندي هذا اذا قاعده
اكلفهم باعمال اعلى من مستوى الدخل اللي
ممكن يجيبونه
فعشان كذا يقول لك اليوم احنا مثلا مع
نقله شاهد
خلقنا كيان اسمهم بي سي استوديوس اللي عمل
رشاش اليوم
فانتاجها فقط حيكون من هذا المستوى احلى
مثلا بكره بتشوف على فكره كندهر
من اعمال اللي احنا اشتغلنا عليها على
فكره في العلا صور في العلا فيلم عالمي
معاويه عمل عظيم
يعني مستوى الاعمال
العالميه ان شاء الله
تشوفونه قريب
عندك
فيلم الان بنصوره في الجديه في
اخر السنه هذه
عن قصه بدايه الاسلام لقصه الرساله
القديمه اللي عملها مصطفى العقاد ولكن حنا
ماخذينها هنا من زاويه ابو بكر الصديق
فاحنا مسمينه الصديق مسمينه فاحنا ماخذين
العمل من زاويه
ابو بكر لابو خالد
بالعكس يعني ارشاش سوى ضجه واوقف ثم نعيد
معاويه سوى ضجه الجابريه اوقف بالكامل هل
هذا نوع من تسويق الاعمال ولا ام بي سي
تتعدل خطوط يعني وش تعليقك على سالفه
الصدام اللي يصير مع كل عمل تنتجون او مع
اغلب الاعمال فكرت اني
حتى عمر كان عليه جدل عبد الله على عمر
اتذكرت يوم يوم قررنا نسوي مسلسل عمر ذاك
الوقت رحت الملك عبد الله الله يرحمه كان
في
وقلت له عندنا فكره نسوي
عمل وكذا
فكان الملك عبد الله مهتم قصه حوار
الاديان ذاك الوقت فقلت له انه يعني في
العمل هذا ان شاء الله يظهر وهذا حقيقي
ومورخ وموجود يعني قصه عمر كيف تعامل مع
المسيحيين ومع اليهود واعطاهم من الزكاه
وهذا حيظهر فتحمس كثير وعجبل عجبت الفكره
وقال لي ابد اتوكلوا على الله واذا بس شفت
ترى بيهجمون وترى بتسمع اشكال والوان ما
ودي انك قبل ما
قبل ما يصلك اذا تكون عندك خلفيه وتعرف
ايش ذا
توكل على الله
وبدانا اشتغلنا طبعا عن الموضوع اتذكر كنت
في اسبانيا ذاك الوقت كان كان في صديق
هناك وقال لي ترى هذا الرجال اللي بيشوفك
وبيجي مخصوص يعني عشان يقابلك
يوم جاني قال لي هذا العمل لازم يوقف
كيف قال لي ابدا هذا العمل مرفوض تماما من
المؤسسه الدينيه قاطبه
وراح يجتمع مجلس
او هيئه الكبار اللي انا مهيئه كبار
العلماء وراح يشترون بيان والعمل بيوقف
احسن لك وقفه من عندك
قلت له طيب على فكره ترى قطر مشاركينا
بالعمل ترى اذا وقفتهم بيعرضونها يعني
يعرضون قطر ولا تعرضه
ايش
المنحطه ام بي سي اي كذا يعني بالهجوم
جايب هالطريقه يعني وانا تراي ناسحن لك
ووقف العمل لازم توقف العمل
خير ان شاء الله
طلع من عندي عرض العمل واستقبل احسن
استقبال
الحمد لله يعني في وقتها
بهذه النوعيات موجوده
يعني حتشوف بكره في اعمال كثيره اكيد
اصوات تطلع من هالنوعيه تستجيبون مثلا
الجابريه ولا لا لا الجابريه
مؤقتا
لا مؤقتا
يمكن في شغلات بسيطه بس طلبت منهم انهم
يعني يعيدون النظر في او يعدلونها ولكن
الايقاف مؤقت وكان بطلب من اخواننا في
الكويت ما كان له علاقه بالسعوديه على
فكره اليوم المملكه ووزاره الاعلام بالذات
هيئه المرء والمسموع من افضل
الجهات الرقابيه او
اللي ممكن
تلجا لها في في ترخيص اي انتاج انا بدي
اختم باخر جزئيات وطولت عليك ابو خالد اسف
بس مستمتع جدا انا باليوم بتكلم مع الخبير
مع المختص مع
الرائد في هذا القطاع
يعني
انت ذكرت في مقابله قبل سبع سنوات انك انت
بنفسك تشوف الاعمال وتقول اذا جيت امور
ماليه واداريه هذه ماني احبها واحولها
فانت تدخل حتى في موضوع المحتوى واجازته
هل هذا صحي لحوكمه مؤسسه اعلاميه ولا هذا
هو الشغف اللي قاعد يدفعك لهذا الاتجاه وش
سر اقترابك من
المنتج النهائي اللي يعرض على الشاشه
والله شوف ابو عبد الرحمن انا ترى انا
قريب من
المبدعين من يعني انا احب اجلس معهم واسمع
منهم انبسط يعني انا استمتع بس ما افرض
عليهم رايي ابدا بالعكس اتعلم منهم يعني
واكيد يعني تراكمات من 30 سنه تعلمت شغلات
منهم يعني تخيل انا
انتجت عوده عصويد تعرف هذا عام كم هذا
يمكن عام 86 ترى اول ما بدات ارى ذاك
الوقت كان محمد علي الله يرحمه وناصر
القصبي وعبد كان توهم يعني بادين ذاك
الوقت ورسم راني ومجموعه كانوا يعني من
ذاك الوقت واحنا نمر بتجارب مختلفه وكل
وقت طبعا على حسب الوقت
انا انا عندي فعلا شغف يعني انا احب
المجلس مع الكتاب وبعدين مع المخرج
ويعطوني تصوراتهم وبعض الاحيان يعني
يشوروني في شغلات خاصه اذا هي سعوديه او
او خليجيه خلينا نقول والمخرج او ذولا
يعني اجانب او عرب يعني في بعض التفاصيل
ما يعرفون احنا نجتمع ونعطيهم بعض
الخلفيات بعض التفاصيل هذه السير هذه ما
يصير هذا ان قال هذا ما ينقال يعني من
هالشغلات او او مع الكتاب بعد
احب هذا الجانب اكثر ما يخرب الحوكمه انه
في تيم المفترض انه هو يجيز المحتوى يتابع
اذا الرئيس معنا وقايل لنا اوكي الفريق
معدلهم بس هذا انا قدمان بعد ما يخلصون
يعني هذول كانوا خلاص انت واخذوا
عطوا اللي عندهم كله يجولنا حنا شغلات
بسيطه اللي يصير او او توكلوا على الله
يعني
دايما اقول لما اقول لهم تعاملوا معاي اني
انا الكلانت يعني لا تعتبرني يعني كان انا
ايه انا ايه انا اللي انا اللي مكلفكم
بالعمل يعني انا انا شاري العمل منكم
فخذوا وجهه نظري من هالناح من هالزاويه مش
اني برايسكم يعني لا تاخذونها من
يعني خذوا واعطوا معاي يعني قولوا لا هذا
نقبل فيها هذا ما نقبل فيه عادي يعني في
هنا سؤال يعني على موضوع القاده الاعلام
السعودي اغلب الاعلام العربي الناجح اليوم
تلقاه نوعا ما مملوك من السعوديين او
اسسوا سعوديين ففيه يعني اكتساح لكن لما
نجي نتكلم على الاثر على
التاثير على الشعوب على
يعني خدمه مصالحنا ما يبدو الموضوع يعكس
حجم وجودنا في الصناعه ليش الاعلام
السعودي ما هو مؤثر اوكي
سؤال انا اعتقد جدا مهم
هذا يعكس
السياسه السعوديه
السياسه السعوديه عمرها ما حاولت انها
تقلج احد او انها تغير فكر احد او انها
تتدخل في شؤون انا قلت لك الملك عبد الله
بسوي العربيه يقول خلهم كلهم يشاركونا غلط
كلمه الاعلام السعودي احنا ما نعتبر نفسنا
اعلام السعوديه يعني اليوم ام بي سي مصر
تنافس القنوات المصريه كلها بمصريتها مو
بانها سعوديه بمصريتها والعاملين فيها
كلهم مصريين وهي القناه الاولى في مصر
بنسب المشاهده
هي قناه مصريه والقناه ام بي سي العراق
قناه عراقيه واللي فيها عراقيين اللي
يعملون فيها كاملين ما فيها سعودي واحد
يشتغل فيها
السعوديه عمرها ما كانت بلد لا تتدخل في
شؤون
الاشقه والدول العربيه الثانيه بالعكس اذا
اذا ما
ساعدت نظر هي في وجهه نظر السعوديه اوكي
وجهه نظرنا معلنه ومعروفه واحنا ننقلها بس
ما نفرضها على احد
فهذه بالعكس هذه تعكس
حنا خلفياتنا وخلفيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولو بختم بسؤال على موضوع
خبرتك وتجربتك 30 سنه لو تهديها لشاب او
مؤسس لكيان اعلامي ولا شخص مهتم بالاعلام
بعدها 30 سنه وش اهم الدروس اللي تعلمتها
او اهم درس وتحب تهديه
العاملين في القطاع او رواد الاعمال او
الشباب المهتمين في القطع
انا دائما احاول انصح عيالي انه اسمع اكثر
ما تحكي
يعني انا مثلا حكينا عن يوم كان يقول لي
على الانترنت والسوبر وين رايحه الدنيا
وين انا كنت افكر هو يحكي وانا قاعد افكر
وش حاحكي وش المواضيع اللي ابغى اطرحها
معاه وشراجع الشغلات اللي في راسي ابغى
اقول ما كنت مركز كثير على هذا الكلام الا
بعدين يوم شفت النتايج فعليا لو انا اخذته
بجديه واخذته كان كان يمكن
اضاف لتجربتي كثير
وعجل
البريكي وعجل
الانتقال ويمكن بعد كان دخلنا في مجالات
اخرى استفدنا منها مع النقل اللي صارت مع
دخول الانترنت في ذاك الوقت يعني من بدايه
التسعينات
وبنفس الوقت
التقنيه قاعده تتغير يعني بشكل سريع جدا
اذا التقنيات والوسائل تتغير بالنسبه
للمجال يعني المحتوى راح يكون مطلوب بغض
النظر عن التقنيه يعني اليوم
النظاره الاب لهذه
الابن اسمها
ممكن تخليك تشوف الفيلم مثل اعظم شاشه
سينما مثلا اوكي هل هذه الغي الفيلم لا
الفيلم
حينشاف مثل ما كان يشوفوا بالسلم حيشوفوها
هنا
لكن لا هي هنا تجربه السينما هو دخل على
تجربه السينما اكثر بالصفاوه بالنقاوه
بالصوت بالسراوند راح يعطيك هذه التجربه
حتى يمكن يكون ثري دي واللي فور دي
هذا اللي انا فهمته من العرض اللي عملوه
بس هذا حياثر على التيتر على دار دور
الارض وليس على
المحتوى المحتوى هنا او هنا بس
الثيتا راح تتاثر
تذكره ويدخل ويشوف الفيلم لا ممكن يشوفه
هنا فالمحتوى هو الباقي المحتوى
بشكل عام يعني
اساسيه بالنسبه
في هالمجال يعني
انكم تطرحون السنه هذه نقدر نشتري
والله علينا بلاش احنا كل
الاحتمالات
المطروحه
مستثمرين او
شركات او كلها كلها مطروحه والى الان يعني
ما عندنا شيء ما في قرار شيء نعلنه
كيان ربحان انتم احنا كان تجاري ربحان
اليوم عندنا توسعات كبيره حتى لو بيصير في
مشاركات او غيرهم ممكن ما يكون على كل
المجموعه الجزم المجموعه مع احد مثل ما
دخلنا بشراكه مع اليوم في موضوع الجيمنج
فكل الاحتمالات مطروحه شكرا لكم ابو خالد
شرفتنا ونورتنا الله يحفظك الله يحفظك عبد
الرحمن شكرا لكم وشكرا في هذا القصير في
اعداد وانتاجه الحلقه ياسر الغانم في
اداره التصوير ياسر كدشه مساعد وفي تصوير
الكواليس عبد الرحمن العبود في تسجيل
الصوت عبد العزيز المزي وفي الاخراج الفني
لمجد القرشي وفي التحرير انس الخليل وفي
الهندسه الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي التلوين
عبد المجيد العطاس وفي الاشراف على
الانتاج غيداء التميمي واصيل بافرض هذا
بودكاست سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]